I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hello everyone. Hi. Guess what we're talking about today. I would do an impression, but it would be horrible. Like I was gonna do like boom, boom the people that their sole job is like,
我是珍娜·菲舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了这部名为《办公室》的终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。大家好。嗨。猜猜我们今天在聊什么。我很想模仿一下，但那肯定糟透了。就像我本来想模仿，比如砰，砰，那些人的唯一工作就像是，
doop, doop, doop, doop, doop, doop, doop, doop, doop, doop, doop. How do you get that job? I don't know. I wouldn't get it because I can't carry a tune. Well, today everybody we're talking about here comes treble. It is season nine, episode five, written by Owen Elexon, directed by Claire Scanlon. Here's what I learned when I watched this episode. Yeah. I found the acapella singing delightful.
嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟。你怎么能找到那种工作的？我不知道。我可找不到，因为我五音不全。好吧，今天各位，我们要聊的是“这里有麻烦”。这是第九季第五集，奥恩·埃莱克森编剧，克莱尔·斯坎伦导演。这是我看这一集时学到的东西。是的。我觉得那些阿卡贝拉清唱太令人愉快了。
I just loved every time they sang. I mean, I love acapella. My husband was in an acapella group. Yeah. We had to dig out some old videos. Oh, really? Oh, yeah. I watched a bunch of his group in the buff
我只是喜欢他们唱歌的每一次。我是说，我喜欢阿卡贝拉。我丈夫曾经是一个阿卡贝拉乐团的成员。是的。我们不得不翻出一些老视频。哦，真的吗？哦，是的。我看了他那个乐团的一堆全裸表演
from University of Colorado. Naked? In the buff? No, yeah. I watched a bunch of his group in the buff from University of Colorado. Naked? In the buff? What? No, that's their name. In the buff is their name. They're the buffaloes. It's like a play on words.
来自科罗拉多大学。赤裸的？全裸的？不，是的。我看了他那个乐团在科罗拉多大学的一堆全裸表演。赤裸的？全裸的？什么？不，那是他们的名字。全裸是他们的名字。他们是水牛队。这就像是一个双关语。
You know, it really sounds like I'm going to watch Naked Singers. I know. I just, did they think this through when they named their group? No. But I'm going to say this. I did look up a bunch of college acapella group names and a lot of them are a little racy. Really? Yeah.
你知道，听起来真像我要去看裸体歌手。我知道。我只是，他们在给乐团起名字的时候有认真想过吗？没有。不过我要这么说。我确实查了许多大学阿卡贝拉乐团的名字，其中很多都有点色情。真的吗？是的。
Well, why don't we start now with a summary? Here it is. Andy brings his college acapella group to the office for a Halloween party performance. However, this is gonna reignite his rivalry with Broccoli Rob. I mean, Broccoli Rob is kind of sneaky. Yeah. And I have some thoughts on his apartment, but we'll get to it. Oh, yeah. Meanwhile, in this episode, Pam and Jim struggle to agree on their level of
好吧，我们为什么不从一个剧情梗概开始呢？就是这样。安迪把他的大学阿卡贝拉乐团带到办公室来进行万圣节派对表演。然而，这重新点燃了他与西兰花罗伯之间的竞争。我是说，西兰花罗伯有点鬼鬼祟祟的。是的。我对他的公寓有些想法，但我们待会儿会说到。哦，是的。与此同时，在这一集中，潘和吉姆难以在他们对吉姆现在加入的体育营销创业公司的财务投入水平上达成一致，
financial participation in the sports marketing startup that Jim is now a part of, and Dwight starts an investigation to find the owner of an anti-anxiety pill he found on the floor. Fast fact number one, the storyline with Andy and his college a cappella group was inspired by our writer Halstead Sullivan's Real Life. Once again, Halstead's Real Life made it into an episode, but this one is fantastic. We reached out to Halstead and we asked him, how did this Andy storyline come about?
德怀特开始调查在地板上发现的一片抗焦虑药的归属。趣味事实一，安迪和他的大学阿卡贝拉乐团的故事线灵感来自我们的编剧霍尔斯特德·沙利文的真实生活。又一次，霍尔斯特德的真实生活被写进了一集里，但这一集太棒了。我们联系了霍尔斯特德并问他，安迪的这个故事线是怎么来的？
He shares about his true life story, you gotta hear it. Hey, Angela and Jenna, thanks so much for asking me to tell your listeners about yet another office story that was loosely based on something that actually happened to me. Though in this case, it's not so loose. To give you some brief history, when I was a student at the University of Virginia,
他分享了他的真实生活故事，你一定要听听。嘿，安吉拉和珍娜，非常感谢你们邀请我向你们的听众讲述又一个办公室故事，这个故事大致基于实际发生在我身上的事情。虽然在这个案例中，并不是那么“大致”。给你们提供一些简短的历史，当我是弗吉尼亚大学的学生时，
I started an acapella group called the Virginia Hullabahoos, and the group is still going strong today. Over the years, the Hullabahoos have sung all across the country. They've sung in Europe and the Philippines. They've sung at the White House for a couple different presidents, and they were even in the first Pitch Perfect movie, where you can see them singing the final countdown at the end of the movie. Now, needless to say, I'm extremely proud of all they've accomplished since I founded
我创立了一个名为弗吉尼亚呼啦巴霍斯的阿卡贝拉乐团，这个乐团至今仍然发展得很好。多年来，呼啦巴霍斯在全国各地演唱过。他们在欧洲和菲律宾演唱过。他们曾在白宫为几位不同的总统演唱过，甚至还出现在第一部《完美音调》电影中，你可以在电影结尾看到他们演唱《最后的倒计时》。不用说，对于自我创立乐团以来他们所取得的一切成就，我感到无比自豪
the group. Oh, so very many years ago. And a couple of years before I was on the office, the current group of guys at the time came out to LA to sing the National Anthem at a Lakers' Gap. They asked if they could stay with me for a couple of days, and of course they said yes. Even though it meant 14 college students staying in our house. And was it hell? Absolutely. But since they were coming to LA, I decided to set up for a concert for them as well.
哦，那是好多年前的事了。在我加入《办公室》之前的几年里，当时的那群小伙子们来到洛杉矶，在湖人队的比赛中演唱国歌。他们问是否可以在我家住几天，我当然答应了。尽管这意味着有14名大学生住在我们家里。那简直是地狱吗？绝对是的。但既然他们要来洛杉矶，我决定也为他们安排一场音乐会。
And I invited alumni and a ton of my friends and it was a nice event. I even paid for the whole bar. To give you a little more backstory, since I was the founder of the group, historically pretty much any time I showed up at a concert, the guys would invite me on stage to sing the song that I sang when I was in the group, which was a song called Run Around Sue. So before this concert, I don't know what got into me, before the guys went on stage, I was like,
我邀请了校友和一大群我的朋友，这是一个很棒的活动。我甚至包了整个酒吧。为了给你们提供更多背景故事，既然我是该团的创始人，历史上几乎任何时候我出现在音乐会上，小伙子们都会邀请我上台演唱我在团里时唱的那首歌，那首歌叫做《四处游荡的苏》。所以在这次音乐会之前，我不知道自己是怎么了，在小伙子们上台之前，我像是，
guys, I know you're gonna pull me up there to sing my signature song, but you really don't have to. This night is yours. Just go have fun. Fully knowing in my heart of hearts, and of course they would invite me up to sing my song. I mean, it had never not happened before. So as I'm in the audience enjoying
伙计们，我知道你们会把我拉上去唱我的标志性歌曲，但你们真的不必这么做。今晚是属于你们的。去玩得开心吧。我内心深处完全清楚，他们当然会邀请我上去唱我的歌。我的意思是，这从来没有不发生过。所以当我在观众席上欣赏
the concert and silently warming up my vocal cords, the guys are singing song after song after song, the audience is loving it, and I'm getting more and more nervous to be about to sing in front of all of my LA friends. and then suddenly the concert's over, and they didn't invite me up to sing my song. I was livid. And was that a rational feeling for an adult man to have? No. But if you think any man who sings four-part harmony without instruments and thinks that
音乐会并默默热身我的声带时，小伙子们一首接一首地唱着歌，观众们非常喜欢，而我对于即将在我所有的洛杉矶朋友面前唱歌感到越来越紧张。然后突然之间音乐会结束了，他们没有邀请我上去唱我的歌。我气炸了。一个成年人有这种感觉理性吗？不。但如果你认为任何不用乐器唱四声部和声并且认为这真的很有趣的男人是理智的，我的朋友们，你们就大错特错了。
it's actually entertaining to people is rational, you are sorely mistaken, my friends. But the story doesn't end there. A few years after that, when we were trying to think of a story for Andy Bernard and Here Comes Trouble, I told the story in the writer's room and it became an episode. And as we were writing, of course, I suggested to Greg that the actual Hullabahoo's play the group Here Comes Trouble, and lo and behold, six of them got cast. But the story doesn't end there. When they came out, I hosted all 14 guys in the group, and the guys who didn't get cast came out to set to watch. And on the last day of shooting, it was actually my birthday. And there on the set, the Hull who's brought out a huge cake
但故事并没有就此结束。几年后，当我们试图为安迪·伯纳德和《这里有麻烦》构思一个故事时，我在编剧室里讲了那个故事，它就变成了一集。在我们写作的过程中，我当然向格雷格建议让真正的呼啦巴霍斯来扮演“这里有麻烦”乐团，果不其然，他们中有六个人被选中了。但故事并没有就此结束。当他们来到这里时，我接待了团里所有的14个小伙子，那些没有被选中的小伙子也来到片场观看。在拍摄的最后一天，实际上是我的生日。就在《办公室》的片场，呼啦巴霍斯为我端出一个巨大的蛋糕，
for me and sang Happy Birthday to me. And then in front of the whole cast and crew of the office, they invited me up to sing my signature song. So I guess if there's a moral to this story is that when life gives you lemons and you don't get asked to sing your signature song, you make lemonade and turn it into an office episode where you get to sing your song in front of your whole office family. But if you want to hear more, you can listen to the Hulb who's on Spotify and Apple Music. Sorry, I couldn't help it.
并为我唱了生日快乐歌。然后在《办公室》全体演员和工作人员面前，他们邀请我上台唱我的标志性歌曲。所以我想如果这个故事有什么寓意的话，那就是当生活给你柠檬，而你没有被邀请唱你的标志性歌曲时，你要做成柠檬水，把它变成一集《办公室》，让你能在整个办公室大家庭面前唱你的歌。但如果你想听更多，你可以在Spotify和Apple Music上听呼啦巴霍斯的歌。抱歉，我情不自禁。
I'm just so damn proud of them. Okay, I'm really done now. Thanks. Oh, and I love that story. I remember them singing on the stages. I do too. And you know, as I remember it, it was Claire's idea to have the happy birthday song
我为他们感到太骄傲了。好了，我真的说完了。谢谢。哦，我喜欢那个故事。我记得他们在舞台上唱歌。我也是。而且你知道，据我记忆所及，在片场为霍尔斯特德唱生日快乐歌是克莱尔的主意。是的，确实是。你知道，我们为这一集联系了克莱尔，她说过的一件事是，他们唱歌和霍尔斯特德唱歌的这一刻是她在这集里最美好的回忆之一，我也是。我也很喜欢她分享说她有一份拷贝，她把它给了霍尔斯特德，他是唯一拥有拷贝的人。没有其他人有。所以霍尔斯特德。好吧，好吧，我们问了霍尔斯特德，他是唯一拥有拷贝的人，没有其他人有。
to Halstead on set. Yes, it was. You know, we reached out to Claire for this episode and one of the things she said was that this moment of them singing and Halstead singing was one of her favorite memories from this episode and mine too. I also love that she shared that she has a copy of it and she gave it to Halstead and he's the only one that has the copy. No one else has it. So Halstead. Well, well, we asked Halstead, and he's the only one that has the copy, no one else has it.
所以霍尔斯特德，好吧，我们问了霍尔斯特德我们是否可以分享它，他说不行，因为他们唱的调子太高了。好吧，霍尔斯特德，我们想邀请你，办公室辣妈，和呼啦巴霍斯一起唱《四处游荡的苏》，我们会在《办公室辣妈》节目中播放它。哦，那将是一种享受。我们还有一个整季的时间，霍尔斯特德。好吧，接下来是趣味事实二，
So Halstead, well, we asked Halstead if we could share it, and he said no, because they sang it in a key too high. Well, Halstead, we would like to invite you, the office ladies, to sing Run Around Sue with the Hullabahoos, and we will play it on Office Ladies. Oh, that would be a treat. We have a whole season left, Halstead. All right, moving on to Fast Fact number two,
你知道那个阿卡贝拉乐团里最后向潘献殷勤的小伙子吗？哦，是的。当吉姆和潘吵架时。是的，这真是一个有趣的场景。所以那个歌手名叫尼克·卡费罗。当他们这样做时，他当时还不是演员，他只是呼啦巴霍斯的一名成员。霍尔斯特德建议我们联系他，听听更多
you know the guy in the acapella group who ends up serenading Pam. Oh yes. While Jim and Pam fight. Yes, it's such a fun scene. So that singer is named Nick Caffero. He was not an actor at the time when When they did this, he was just a member of the Hullabahoos. Halstead suggested that we reach out to him to hear a little bit more
关于所有这些小伙子突然被邀请参加《办公室》是什么感觉。尼克发来了一段音频剪辑。我们去听听吧。办公室辣妈。哦天哪。我简直不敢相信我现在在录这个。这太让人激动了。太荣幸了。我很高兴你们邀请我参与其中。我是你们两个、这个播客以及《办公室》的超级粉丝。这就像梦想成真一样。非常感谢你们邀请我参与其中。所以我是大学三年级学生。我在弗吉尼亚大学。所以记得当时我是乐团的主席。我收到了一封电子邮件，说他们想让我们
about what it was like for all these guys to suddenly be invited to be on the office. And Nick sent in an audio clip. We got to hear it. Office ladies. Oh my goodness. I cannot believe I am recording this right now. This is such a thrill. Such an honor. I'm so excited that you asked me to be part of this. I am a huge fan of the two of you of this podcast and of course of the office. And this is like a dream come true. Thank you so much for asking me to be part of this. So I was a junior in college. I was at the University of Virginia. So I remember I was the president of the group at the time. I got an email saying that they wanted us
去为《办公室》试镜。我以为是个恶作剧，但当我把心率降下来并弄清楚它是真的之后，我把乐团聚在了一起。我们有18名成员，我把我们所有人都录了像。回想起来，我根本不知道自己在做什么。所以这些试镜，它们都是在我的宿舍里完成的。
to audition for the office. I thought it was a prank, but once I kind of got my heart rate down and figured out it was real, I got the group together. There were 18 members of us and I put all of us on tape. And looking back on it, I had zero idea what I was doing. So these auditions are, they were all done in my dorm room.
那里的光线和背景可能是你能想象到的最糟糕的，可能还有你能想象到的最糟糕的表演。但我们一个接一个地做场景并唱了一首歌，因为这个角色需要我们唱歌。我们唱了埃德温·麦凯恩的《I'll Be》，这实际上是我最后在节目中对你唱的，珍娜。我记得在把试镜寄给制片人和选角导演之前，先寄给了霍尔斯特德。
They have the worst lighting in background you could possibly imagine, and probably some of the worst acting you could possibly imagine. But we all did the scene one by one and sang a song because the role required us to sing. And we sang I'll Be by Edwin McCain, which is actually what I ended up singing on the show to you, Jenna. And I remember sending all the auditions into Halstead first
而霍尔斯特德的反应是，嗯，你们需要重做这些。这些太糟糕了。所以我们最终重做所有这些，显然这是最好的结果。然后我把它们寄了出去。几天后，我接到一个电话，说我们被选中出演《办公室》的一集，而我被选中扮演那个有台词和唱歌的角色。我差点吐了。不幸的是，18名成员中只有7人
before I sent them into the producers and casting. And Halstead was like, um, you need to redo these. These are terrible. So we ended up redoing all of them, which was for the best, obviously. And then I sent them in. And a few days later, I got a call saying that we've been cast on an episode of the office and I was cast in the role that would be speaking and singing. And I almost threw up. Unfortunately, only seven of the 18 members
被邀请参加节目。但我们做的是，我们把我们七个人将要获得的报酬全部拿出来，用来买机票，以便团里的其余人也能出来体验这一切，并在洛杉矶玩得开心。尼克，那个故事太疯狂了。我无法想象收到那封电子邮件。但我要说的是，为什么我们没有给这些小伙子买机票让他们飞过来？什么？我不知道。
in the hullabahoo's were asked to be on the show. But what we did is we took all the money that we were going to get paid, the seven of us, and we used that to buy plane tickets so that the rest of the group could come out and experience this too and have fun in LA. Nick, that story is bonkers. I cannot imagine getting that email. But here's what I have to say. Why did we not fly these guys out? What? I don't know.
我是说，我想也许我们让被选中的小伙子们飞了过来，然后他们花自己的钱让其他人飞过来。听起来是这样的。谢天谢地，安吉拉，因为当我第一次听到那个时，我想，什么？不，不，不，我想他们用他们的薪水让那些没有被选中的人飞了过来。
I mean, I guess maybe we flew out the guys that got cast and then they spent their money to fly out these other people. That's what it sounds like. Well, thank God, Angela, because when I first listened to that, I thought, what? No, no, no, I think they used their salaries to fly out the people that didn't.
团里的其他人。是的，这非常贴心。有档次，非常有档次。好吧，除了在他们到那儿时见到整个《办公室》的演员阵容外，尼克与我们分享的另一件事是布莱恩·科兰斯顿也在四处走动，因为他在那里为《工作巴士》做后期制作。
The rest of the group. Yes, which was very sweet. Classy, very classy. Well, in addition to meeting the entire office cast while they were there, another thing that Nick shared with us was that Brian Cranston was also walking around because he was there doing post-production on work bus.
这真的让他们大吃一惊。是的，他们当时想，等等，我以为我们是来——制作《工作巴士》。这真的让他们大吃一惊。是的。他们当时想，等等，我以为我们是来《办公室》工作的。这到底是怎么回事？为什么老白会在这儿？是的。好吧，尼克分享了更多他在片场的经历。
And that really threw them. Yes, they were like, wait, I thought we were coming-production on Work Bus. And that really threw them. Yes. And they were like, wait, I thought we were coming to work on the office. What is happening? Why is Walter White here? Yeah. Well, Nick shared a few more stories
我们会在这一集的各个地方穿插这些内容。现在我要带大家进入趣味事实三，安吉拉，斯蒂芬·科尔伯特饰演的西兰花罗伯。我太相信安迪和西兰花罗伯之间的竞争了。我真的相信。哦，西兰花罗伯太阴险了。他太会进行煤气灯操控了，不是吗？
from his time on the set. We'll sprinkle those throughout this episode. And now I'm gonna move us on to Fast Fact number three, Angela, Stephen Colbert as Broccoli Rob. I so believed Andy and Broccoli Rob's rivalry. I really believed it. Oh, Broccoli Rob is insidious. He's so gaslighty, isn't he?
是的。我们收到了来自亚利桑那州汉娜·埃伦的一个粉丝提问，她说，你们有机会见到斯蒂芬·科尔伯特吗？还是他只出现在视频通话中？好吧，首先，汉娜，我要说的是，埃德是我们通过他们在《每日秀》共事时的经历与斯蒂芬·科尔伯特建立的联系。不幸的是，我们没有机会见到他。他在纽约拍摄了他所有的戏份。
Yeah. We had a fan question from Hannah Ellen Arizona who said, did you guys get to meet Stephen Colbert? Or was he only on the video call? Well, first of all, Hannah, I'll say that Ed was our connection to Stephen Colbert from their time on The Daily Show. And unfortunately, we did not get to meet him. He filmed all his stuff in New York.
他们很早就开始拍了。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说他们在纽约为罗伯搭建了一个布景。他们在那里架设了摄像机拍摄他。他们还把他连线到视频通话中。这非常精心。没错，会议室的场景。是的，还有休息室。对于任何不知道的人来说，斯蒂芬·科尔伯特是个很棒的歌手。他上高中时加入过合唱团。你知道他也曾因唱歌赢得过格莱美奖吗？是的，这个我不知道。
They did it really early in the morning. Steve Burgess said they set Rob up on a set in New York. They had a camera filming him there. They also put him on a video call. It was very elaborate. Right, the conference room scenes. Yeah, and in the break room. For anyone who doesn't know, Stephen Colbert is a great singer. He was in the Glee Club in high school. Did you know that he's also won a Grammy for singing? Yes, that I did not know.
好吧，在2008年，他发行了一张CD，并有一个名为《科尔伯特圣诞节：最棒的礼物》的电视特别节目，该节目赢得了最佳喜剧专辑格莱美奖。在2011年，他在林肯中心与纽约爱乐乐团合作的音乐剧《公司》音乐会中饰演了哈里一角。在林肯中心。哇。我做不到。那是大人物级别的，伙计们。
Well, in 2008, he released a CD and had a TV special called A Cold Bear Christmas, The Greatest Gift of All, which won a Grammy Award for Best Comedy Album. And at 2011, he performed the role of Harry in the musical company in concert with the New York Philharmonic at Lincoln Center. At Lincoln Center. Wow. I couldn't do it. That's big time, guys.
我是说，我做不到，因为另外我也不会唱歌，他们绝不会让我去那儿。我做不到，因为还是那句话，五音不全。你真的五音不全吗？差不多吧。我不知道你这样。如果我和其他人一起唱，我可以，但如果你说，来吧，安吉。
I mean, I couldn't do it because also I can't sing and they would never have me there. I couldn't do it because, again, can't carry a tune. You really can't carry a tune? Not really. I didn't know that about you. I can if I'm singing with other people, but then if you say, take it, Ange.
我会唱前几句。然后我就想，我在哪儿？我们要去哪儿？这是要去哪儿？如果你不得不带头唱生日快乐歌会发生什么？哦，好吧，我可以唱生日快乐。你起头起得好吗？但有些人起头起得糟糕透顶。
I'll get like the first few. And then I'm like, where am I going? Where are we going? Where is this going? What happens if you have to start happy birthday? Oh, well, I can do happy birthday. Do you start it okay? But some people start it terribly.
你怎么会起头起得糟糕透顶？生日快乐。你起调太高了。或者你就像，祝你生日快乐。然后你会觉得，人们，人们会这样。我就想，只要为整个团队起一个中性的调子就行了。是的。是的。祝你生日快乐。是的。就在那儿起头。每个人都可以在那里唱。我可以用韩语唱歌。很明显。大家介意。那个牛肉。如果你在珍娜周围唱生日快乐，要小心警告。如果我在扮演一个角色，我可以唱歌。
How do you start it terribly? Happy birthday. You start too high. Or you're like, happy birthday to you. And you're like, people, people do it. I'm like, just start it neutral for the whole group. Yeah. Yeah. Happy birthday to you. Yes. Start it there. Everyone can sing it there. I can sing in Korean. Clearly. That people mind. That beef. Warning if you sing happy birthday around Jenna. I can sing if I'm doing a character.
另外有些教堂的歌我觉得我可以把调子唱准，只是因为我唱过太多次了。我在教堂最喜欢的部分就是唱歌。是的。我会大声唱出来。我也是。他将用鹰翼托起你。
And also there's some songs from church that I feel like I can carry the tune just cause I've sung them so many times. My favorite part of church was the singing. Yeah. And I would sing out. Me too. And he will raise you up on Eagles wings.
是的。是的。有一首歌，当然，你知道，我的家庭就像是南方风格的。我会非常大声地吼出来，那是在复活节，歌词会是，没有什么坟墓能留住我的身体。是的。
Yes. Yeah. There was a song, of course, you know, my family is like Southern. I would belt out so hard and it was at Easter and it would be like, there ain't no grave gonna hold my body down. Yeah.
那是关于复活节的。我全力以赴了。我们最近回家时去了一座教堂，我开始大声唱一首歌，我女儿看着我的眼神就像是，你能把音量调小一点吗？我是说，教堂大部分时间都很无聊。让我们诚实点。
And it's about the resurrection. And I went for it. We were at church recently when I went back home and I started to belt out a song and my daughter looked at me like, what can you dial down the volume? I mean, most of church is boring. Let's be honest.
珍娜，确实如此。拜托。为什么我不能说我们都知道的事？你可以，而且你也这么做了。我就要50岁了。我离50岁只有几步之遥了，一切都要倾泻而出了。一切都要倾泻而出了。哦，好吧，我们是要休息一下然后进入这一集还是我们在干嘛？一切都要倾泻而出了。一切都要倾泻而出了。
Jenna, it is. Come on. Why can't I say stuff we all know? You can and you do. I'm going to be 50. I'm moments away from 50 and it's all coming out. It's all coming out. Oh, well, are we going to take a break and then get into this episode or what are we doing? and it's all coming out. It's all coming out.
好吧，我们是要休息一下然后进入这一集还是我们在干嘛？我们休息一下吧。我们休息一下吧。给我来一块那个播客节目。我们回来了。在我们开始剖析这一集之前，我有一些来自通告单的花絮。哦是吗？多亏了史蒂夫·伯吉斯。我们于2012年9月10日星期一开始拍摄这一集。你好奇我们在《这里有麻烦》的第一天拍了什么吗？是的。
Well, are we gonna take a break and then get into this episode or what are we doing? Let's take a break. Let's take a break. Break me off a piece of that podcast show. We are back. And before we start breaking down this episode, I've got some tidbits from the call sheet. Oh yeah? Thanks to Steve Burgess. We started filming this episode on Monday, September 10th, 2012. Are you curious what we filmed on that very first day of Here Comes Trouble? Yes.
很好，我希望你好奇。因为我要告诉你们，全都是单人访谈镜头。整个上午，你在这一集里看到的所有的单人访谈镜头，我们都是在第一天拍摄的。然后在快到傍晚时，我们在办公大区有两个大型群戏场景。对我们节目来说，这是一个非常非常忙碌的制作周。然后在快到傍晚时，我们在办公大区有两个大型群戏场景。对我们节目来说，这是一个非常非常忙碌的制作周。
Good, I hope you are. Cause I'm gonna tell you, it was all talking heads. All morning, all the talking heads you see in the episode, we were filming on the first day. And then towards the end of the day, we did have two big group scenes in the bullpen. And it was a very, very busy production week for our show. Towards the end of the day, we did have two big group scenes in the bullpen. And it was a very, very busy production week for our show.
他们在为农场和船只做准备。农场有一项泥土测试。所以有人被把泥土扔在脸上，看看效果会怎样。他们正在为船只寻找外景地。这周我们有一个NBC的EPK摄制组在采访所有的演员。是的，好吧，那是因为这是我们有史以来的最后一个万圣节单集。有史以来。
They were prepping the farm and the boat. There was a dirt test for the farm. So someone was getting dirt thrown in their face to see how it would look. They were scouting locations for the boat. We had an NBC EPK crew doing interviews with all the cast this week. Yes, well that is because this was our last Halloween episode ever. Ever.
噢。我们都接受了关于它的采访，以及我们对此的感受。是的。基本上我们都感到很难过，因为这是我们的最后一个万圣节，但也很感激我们能够制作一个完整的万圣节单集。我记得很高兴我们整周都能穿着服装。是的。好吧，最后，最高气温是89度。谢谢。
Aw. And we all did interviews about it and how we were feeling about it. Yeah. And basically we were all feeling sad that it was our last one, but also grateful that we got to do a full Halloween episode. I remember being excited that we got to be in costume the whole week. Yeah. Well, lastly, the high was 89 degrees. Thank you.
这周气温在80多度。那挺好的。这是一个进步。好吧，就像我们说的，这是我们的万圣节单集，德怀特头上套着一个巨大的南瓜走进办公室。他吓到了艾琳。哦天哪，每个万圣节我到处都能看到雷恩顶着南瓜头的这张照片。嗯哼。就像在T恤上，在贴纸上。到处都是。好吧，有个问题。他摘不下南瓜头。他摘不下来。我们收到了来自明尼苏达州明尼阿波利斯的奥利维亚·H的粉丝提问，她说，德怀特南瓜头冷开场是我整个系列中最喜欢的冷开场。每当我感到沮丧时我都会看它，它总能点亮我的一天。
It was in the 80s this week. That's nice. It's an improvement. Well, like we said, this is our Halloween episode, and Dwight is going to enter the office with a giant pumpkin on his head. He scares Aaron. Oh my gosh, every Halloween I see this picture of rain with the pumpkin head everywhere. Mm-hmm. It's like on t-shirts, on stickers. It's everywhere. Well, there's a problem. He can't get the pumpkin head off. He cannot. We had a fan question from Olivia H. in Minneapolis, Minnesota, who said, The Dwight Pumpkin Head cold open is my single favorite cold open in the entire series. I watch it whenever I'm feeling down and it never fails to brighten my day.
请告诉我一切。有什么场景被剪掉吗？我必须知道。还有来自德州雪松公园的中学生米娅·欧想知道南瓜是不是真的。我们有答案了。米娅，我来告诉你。我们用了一个真南瓜来让雷恩试戴。我们雕刻了一个和那个一样的南瓜。但在大约开拍前一周，服装师把那个真南瓜带给了一个模具工，他制作了一个玻璃钢版本
Please tell me everything. Were there any scenes cut out? I must know. And Mia Oh, a middle schooler from Cedar Park, Texas, wanted to know if the pumpkin was real. We have the answers. Mia, I'll tell you this. We used a real pumpkin to fit rain. We carved out a pumpkin just like that. But about a week before the episode, the costumers took that real pumpkin to a molder who made a fiberglass version
因为我们不想让它腐烂或破裂。没错。史蒂夫·伯吉斯给我们发了一张非常搞笑的照片，照片里雷恩头上戴着玻璃钢南瓜，试图通过眼孔阅读他的台词。是的。所以雷恩确实戴着那个东西走来走去了一段时间。我得说史蒂夫给我们发了很棒的照片。他还给我发了一张我从未见过的我和参议员的照片，扮演南希和罗纳德·里根。
because we didn't want it to rot or break. Right. And Steve Burgess sent us a very funny photo of Rain with the fiberglass pumpkin on his head trying to read his sides through the eye hole. Yeah. So Rain really did walk around with that thing for a while. I should say Steve sends us great pictures. He also sent me a photo I had never seen of myself and the senator as Nancy and Ronald Reagan.
我会把这些都发在快拍里。克莱尔也给我们发了一大堆精美的照片。这周我们会在Instagram上有很多照片。是的，很多幕后照片。奥利维亚，为了回答你的问题，还有几个德怀特头上戴着这个南瓜的场景。最终，在被删减的场景中发生的是，德怀特顶着巨大的南瓜头倒车离开停车场，他的车撞上了一排树篱。他的头有点猛撞在车内侧，
I'll put all of these in stories. Claire sent us a ton of great pictures too. We're gonna have a lot of pictures for Instagram this week. Yes, a lot of behind-the-scenes photos. And Olivia, to answer your question, there were several more scenes with Dwight with this pumpkin on his head. Ultimately, what happens in deleted scenes is Dwight is backing out of the parking lot with the big pumpkin head, and his car hits the row of hedges. His head kind of slams into the side of the car's interior,
南瓜开始从中间裂开，他得以脱身。哦，所以我们看到了他获救。是的，他把南瓜碎片扔出窗外，然后就像是，哈哈，然后他开车走了。我们的导演克莱尔跟我们分享说，那个场景实际上非常难拍摄。她说那个南瓜头太大了，以至于他们不得不把驾驶座从车里拆下来，这样雷恩才能真的进到车里，他们才能拍他
and the pumpkin starts to break in half, and he's able to free himself. Oh, so we got to see him freed. Yes, and he throws the pumpkin pieces out the window, and is like, ha- ha, and he drives off. And Claire, our director shared with us that the scene was actually really difficult to shoot. She said that pumpkin head was so big that they had to pull the driver's seat out of the car so rain could physically get in the car and they could film him
顶着南瓜头坐进车里的画面。是的。然后在经历了所有这些麻烦之后，他们从来没有使用任何他坐进车里的镜头。是的。然后在经历了所有这些麻烦之后，他们从来没有使用任何他坐进车里的镜头。克莱尔还分享说，当他们在拍雷恩顶着南瓜头的单人访谈时，起初他们以为可以在他嘴里塞进任何台词，因为南瓜差不多把所有东西都遮住了。但后来他们在剪辑时意识到，你仍然可以看到他的嘴在动。她说，如果你仔细看，它有点不同步。
with the pumpkin head getting in the car. Yeah. And then after all that trouble, they never use any of the footage of him getting in the car. Yeah. And then after all that trouble, they never used any of the footage of him getting in the car. Claire also shared that when they were shooting Reigns talking head with the pumpkin head on that at first they thought that they could just put any words in his mouth because the pumpkin kind of covered everything. But then they realized when they got an editing that you could still see his mouth kind of moving. And she said, if you look close enough, it's a little bit out of sync.
当他说南瓜应该在一两个月内从我头上烂掉时，它并不完全匹配。完全对不上。我可以告诉你们，我查了万圣节戴南瓜头的人，比如人们在这样做吗？我确实发现有些人这样做了。他们像德怀特一样雕刻南瓜？真的吗？是的，他们拍了自己的照片，那些TikTok博主。
When he says the pumpkin should rot off my head in a month or two, it doesn't totally match. It doesn't play match, exactly. I will tell you that I looked up people wearing pumpkin heads at Halloween, like are people doing this? I did find some people did this. They carved out a pumpkin like Dwight. Really? Yes, and they took photos of themselves, the Tik Tokers.
TikTok博主做了这件事？TikTok博主做了这件事。然后我很想知道你是否能买到像德怀特戴的那种南瓜头，然后制作你自己的万圣节服装。我在亚马逊上确实找到了毛绒版本。我很惊讶这不是一套服装。是的。好吧，安吉拉，我们收到了来自挪威的艾拉·R的一个有趣的粉丝提问，我想
The Tokers did it? The Tokers did it. And then I was curious if you could buy a pumpkin head like the one Dwight wore and make your own Halloween costume. I did find a plushy version on Amazon. I'm surprised this isn't a costume. Yeah. Well, we got an interesting fan question from Aila R. in Norway, Angela, that I thought
也许我们可以讨论一下。好的。艾拉指出，为了制作他的服装，德怀特必须挖空南瓜的底部。他必须在南瓜底部开个洞。当然。把所有的东西都掏出来。是的。艾拉说这让她想起了关于雕刻南瓜最佳方法的巨大争论。
maybe we could discuss. Okay. Aila notes that in order to make his costume, Dwight had to carve out the bottom of the pumpkin. He had to put the hole in the bottom of the pumpkin. Sure. Pull all the stuff out. Yes. And Aila said that this reminded her of the big debate
你是在顶部开个洞然后从顶部掏空吗？还是你在底部开个洞然后从底部掏空？艾拉想知道，我们是怎么处理我们的南瓜的？艾拉，我不知道还有一个伟大的南瓜争论。我总是弄顶部然后做一个小帽子。是的。
over the best way to carve a pumpkin. Do you cut a hole in the top and scoop it out from the top? Or do you put a hole in the bottom and scoop it out from the bottom? Aila wanted to know, how do we do our pumpkins? Aila, I did not know there was a great pumpkin debate. I always do the top and then make a little hat. Yep.
好吧，在我成长过程中，我的家庭是切掉南瓜的顶部。是的。那是我们的方式。我在成年后继续用那种方式做。这是要去哪儿？我觉得有人改变了你。我来告诉你谁改变了谁。谁？我来告诉你谁改变了谁。谁？和巴巴斯吃早午餐
Well, growing up, my family cut off the top of the pumpkin. Yeah. That was our way. I continued to do it that way in my adult life. Where is this going? I feel like someone changed you. I'll tell you who changed me. Who? tell you who changed me. Who brunch with Babs brunch with Babs
你不关注和巴巴斯吃早午餐吗？我在Instagram上好吧，现在我觉得我被无视了，因为我不知道谁是和巴巴斯吃早午餐。和巴巴斯吃早午餐就像是 给你所有事情各种秘籍的妈妈。好吧。生活中所有最好的妈妈秘籍，好吗？和巴巴斯吃早午餐。太棒了。
You don't follow brunch with Babs. I on Instagram Well now I feel like I'm getting shade because I don't know who brunch with Babs is brunch with Babs is like Your mom who's giving you all the hacks on everything. Okay. In life, all the best mom hacks, okay? Brunch with Babs. Great.
我两年前看过她的一个视频，她教你如何雕刻南瓜，她在底部切出一个圆圈，然后她使用搅拌机。哦，她把它全部掏空了。她用搅拌机把所有的南瓜瓤都弄出来了。它把它松散了。然后最棒的是当你点蜡烛时，
I saw a video of hers two years ago where she teaches you how to carve a pumpkin and she cuts out a circle on the bottom and then she uses a mixer. Oh, and she gets it all scooped out. And she gets all the guts out with the mixer. It loosens it up. And then what's great about it is when you do the candle,
你只需把南瓜放在蜡烛上面。你不必像以前那样把手从顶部伸进去，试图通过顶部点亮它以及所有那些事。另外，你不会把蜡烛放在任何南瓜上面。你只需把蜡烛放在地上。和巴巴斯吃早午餐。哇。所以无论如何，艾拉，在伟大的南瓜雕刻争论中，我现在是个“底部党”。
you just set your pumpkin on top of the candle. You don't have to like dip your hand down through the top and try to light it through the top and all that business. Also, you're not setting the candle on top of any pumpkin. You just set the candle on the ground. Brunch with baps. Wow. So anyway, Aila, in the great pumpkin carving debate, I'm a now a bottom.
她是底部党。我可能得试试看。这个万圣节，你可能会成为底部党。哦天哪。好吧。我们到哪儿了？吉姆和潘现在要来上班了。吉姆又一次没有穿万圣节服装。
She's a bottom. I might have to try it. This next Halloween, you might be a bottom. Oh my God. Okay. Where are we? Jim and Pam are now gonna arrive to work. Jim once again doesn't have a costume.
是的。好吧，他是黑衣人。我真的很喜欢他压低声音对潘说，把你的墨镜给我。每当有这种压低声音的小台词时，总是能戳中我。潘打扮成灰姑娘医生，他们把艾琳的服装误认为是一只狗。她是一只小狗。
Yeah. Well, he's men in black. I did love under his breath when he was like, give me your sunglasses to Pam. Anytime there's like a little under your breath line, those always got me. Pam is dressed as Dr. Cinderella and they mistake Erin's costume for a dog. She's a puppy.
她是一只小狗。就像我们说的，这是我们的最后一个万圣节，我们最后一次穿服装。女士们，我为我们准备了一份服装明细。你们想听吗？你知道的，我想听。我喜欢服装明细。好的。安迪是乔治·迈克尔，被误认为是美国偶像校友亚当·兰伯特。潘，我说，灰姑娘医生，吉姆，可能是黑衣人特工。凯文是查理·布朗。斯坦利是尤塞恩·博尔特。德怀特是土豚萨里巴斯。我以为他只是戴着猪鼻子。达瑞尔是牛仔。梅雷迪思是黑寡妇。安吉拉是南希·里根。参议员是罗纳德·里根。奥斯卡是恐龙，
She's a puppy. Like we said, this was our last Halloween episode, our last time wearing costumes. Lady, I've got a costume breakdown for us. Do you want to hear it? You know, I do. I love a costume breakdown. All right. Andy is George Michael, mistaken for American Idol alum Adam Lambert. Pam, I said, Dr. Cinderella, Jim, maybe a Men in Black agent. Kevin is Charlie Brown. Stanley is Usain Bolt. Dwight is Saribas the Ardvark. I thought he just had a pig nose on. Darryl is a cowboy. Meredith is Black Widow. Angela is Nancy Reagan. The senator is Ronald Reagan. Oscar is a cowboy, Meredith is Black Widow, Angela is Nancy Reagan, the Senator is Ronald
又名选举人团，艾琳是小狗，菲利斯是啦啦队长，内莉是性感的托比，皮特、克拉克和托比没有打扮，而克里德谋杀了几个人。他只是出现了。他穿着血溅衬衫。他甚至不知道那是万圣节。结果还挺好。那是我的最爱段落之一。我不知道哪个编剧要为此负责，但这真是一个好笑的笑话。
Reagan, Oscar is a dinosaur, aka the Electoral College, Aaron is a puppy, Phyllis is a cheerleader, Nellie is sexy Toby, Pete Clark and Toby didn't dress up, and Creed murdered someone. He just showed up. He didn't splatter shirt. He didn't even know it was Halloween. That worked out well. That is one of my favorite bits. I don't know why that is a funny joke.
吉姆和潘现在要有一个联合单人访谈。我们发现体育营销工作有一个大的投资会议。是的，这就是吉姆没有打扮的原因。是的，就好像他本来会打扮一样。这就是吉姆没有打扮的原因。是的。就好像他本来会打扮一样。
I don't know which writer is responsible for that, but that's a funny joke. Jim and Pam are now gonna have a joint talking head. We find out there's a big investment meeting for the sports marketing job. Yes, this is why Jim didn't dress up. Yes, and as if he was gonna dress up anyway. is why Jim didn't dress up. Yes. And as if he was gonna dress up anyway.
他才不会呢。潘在这个单人访谈中有很多讽刺。我是说，你知道，她有点一直回到那件事，比如，除非你告诉了所有人，除了我，你知道，有点像那样。我想，如果潘在工作时这么说，家里在说什么样的话？她气疯了。她还在生气。潘用讽刺和幽默来处理她的情绪，但我给它打了引号。是的，
He wasn't going to. There is a lot of sass in this talking head from Pam. I mean, you know, she kind of keeps going back to that thing, like, unless you told everyone, but me, you know, kind of like that thing. And I thought, if Pam is saying this at work, what kind of shiitake is being said at home? She is pissed. She is still pissed. Pam is handling her feelings with sarcasm and humor, but I put that in quotes. Yeah,
我觉得这更像是愤怒的讽刺。好吧，各位，乔治·迈克尔就要到了。呜呼。呜。安吉拉分享说参议员稍后会加入他们。我太喜欢安迪说的那句，那是一个问题吗？她说，不，不是的。不，不。然后安迪要介绍一些麻烦。是的。他们唱着歌走进办公大区，
I think it's more just like angry sarcasm. Yes. All right, everybody, George Michael is about to arrive. Woohoo. Woo. Angela shares that the senator will be joining them later. I loved it when Andy was like, was that a question? She goes, no, it was not. No, no. And then Andy is going to introduce some treble. Yeah. They come into the bullpen singing,
我真的很想让你们听听。哦，女士们先生们，这里有麻烦了！我是一个没有信念的人。你来又去，你来又去。如果你的颜色像我的梦想，爱就会很容易。红、金、绿，红、金、绿。来吧，来吧。所以，我最喜欢的事情是当阿卡贝拉乐团以这样一个短促的收尾结束歌曲时。
and I really want you guys to hear it. Oh, ladies and gentlemen, here comes Treville! I'm a man without conviction. You come and go, you come and go. Love will be easy if your colors will like my dream. Red, gold and green, red, gold and green. Come on, come on. So my favorite thing is when acapella groups into song with like a little button like that.
来吧，来吧。是的。这简直太棒了。安吉拉，我们有一个来自加拿大魁北克的丹尼尔·G的粉丝提问，他说，我最喜欢的安吉拉时刻就在这一集中。你也是他最喜欢的角色。丹尼尔，谢谢你。丹尼尔说，请谈谈当奥斯卡跟着《变色龙》一起唱歌时你给他的那个眼神，太搞笑了，我也注意到了。
Come on, come on. Yeah. It's like the best. Angela, we got a fan question for you from Daniel G in Quebec, Canada. Who said, my favorite Angela moment is in this episode. You are also his favorite character. Daniel, thank you. Daniel said, please talk about the look you give Oscar when he is singing along to karma chameleon it is so funny i saw it too.
我知道，我很惊讶它居然播出了，甚至当我看到那一集时也是，所以事情是这样的，丹尼尔，那不是剧本里写的，我只是做出了给奥斯卡一个非常长、充满审视的眼神的选择。长而充满审视的眼神。当时我甚至不知道摄像机操作员捕捉到了它，直到它播出我才看到，这也把我逗乐了。太完美了。我太喜欢了。我确实想和你们分享关于那个南希·里根假发的事。哦是吗？当他们把它戴上时，一整天都摘不下来。所以我一直带着那个。是的。我把好多头发塞进了一个假发网里，然后有所有这些发夹。基本上他们就像是，安吉，你一整天都得从腰部以上扮演南希·里根。我穿着这件西装，夹克下面是一件像背心一样的连体衣，那是西装的一部分，我戴着假发根本套不过头。
I know i was surprised it made it in even when i saw the episode so here's the thing daniel that was not scripted i just made the choice to give Oscar a really long judgy look. long, judgy look. And at the time, I didn't even know the camera operators caught it, and I didn't see it until it aired, and it cracked me up too. It was perfect. I so loved it. I do want to share it with you guys about that Nancy Reagan wig. Oh yeah? When they put it on, they couldn't take it off for the whole day. So I have had that. Yeah. I had tucked so much hair up into a wig cap and then there were all these bobby pins. So basically they were like, Ange, you have to be Nancy Reagan from the
外面气温89度，我穿着这件羊毛背心式的上衣，还有牛仔裤和人字拖。这就是我吃午饭时四处走动的方式。但这个假发把每个人的脑子都搞乱了。我走到拐角处说，嘿，他们就会说，哦天哪，它把所有人都吓坏了。有一天吃午饭时，我女儿来到片场，她就像是，不，不，不，不，妈妈，不，不，妈妈。
waist up all day. I had this suit on and under the jacket was this like tank top that was part of the suit, which I couldn't get over my head with the wig on. And so it's 89 degrees out and I have this wool vest sort of tank top and my jeans and flip flops. And that's how I walked around at lunch. But this wig messed with everyone's brain. I would come around the corner and be like, Hey, and they'd be like, Oh my God, it's just freaked everyone out. And one day for lunch, my daughter came to set and she was like, no, no, no, no, mama, no, no, mama.
她就像是，把那个假发弄掉。但我一整天都摘不下来。是的，我为《永不止步》戴过假发，情况也是一样的。他们把你的头发卷成小发卷贴在头上。他们戴上这个秃头帽，然后把它粘在你头上，这需要很长时间。是的，然后你就陷在里面了。你陷在里面了。你陷在里面了。而且你穿着在你戴上它之前穿的任何衣服，这需要很长时间。是的，然后你就陷在里面了。
She was like, get rid of that wig. But I couldn't take it off all day. Yeah, I had to wear wigs for walk hard and it was the same thing. They do the little pin curls of your hair to your head. They put on this bald cap and then they stick it on you and it takes a long time. Yeah, and then you're in it. You're in it. You're in it. And you're in whatever clothes you were in before you got it on you and it takes a long time. Yeah, and then you're in it.
你陷在里面了。你陷在里面了。而且你还穿着在你戴上它之前穿的那些衣服。是的，你，特别是珍娜，这个假发真的把你逗乐了。你几乎不敢看我。我记得我走到你身边
You're in it. You're in it. And you're in whatever clothes you were in before you got it on too. Yeah, and you, Jenna in particular, this wig really tickled you. You could barely look at me. I remember I walked up to you just like
就在休息时吃芝士条，你就像是，我不能，我不能像那样看着你戴着那个假发。你在吃芝士。好吧，安迪接着解释说这些人是康奈尔大学的阿卡贝拉乐团。这里有麻烦，他们今天将在万圣节派对上为我们大家表演。梅雷迪思想多了解一点
on a break eating a cheese stick and you're like, I can't, I can't like look at you in that wig. You're eating cheese. Well, Andy's gonna go on to explain that these guys are from the Cornell acapella group. Here comes trouble and they will be performing for all of us at the Halloween party today. Meredith would like to know a little bit more
关于这些人在城里的住宿安排。哦，梅雷迪思。给所有这些小伙子们。斯坦利只说他不感兴趣。我对听那个不感兴趣。他根本不在乎。安迪将有一个单人访谈，他说，你知道吗，他刚刚意识到，
about the sleeping arrangements. Oh, Meredith. For all these guys while they're in town. Stanley just says he's not interested. I'm not interested in sitting through that. He doesn't care. Andy's gonna have a talking head where he says, you know what, he just realized,
他刚刚意识到他们可能会叫他上去唱他的标志性歌曲《信仰》。哦天哪，我打扮成乔治·迈克尔，而他们可能会叫我上去唱《信仰》，拜托。他毫无准备。哦，他完全没有准备。他甚至根本没有认真想过这件事。吉姆现在要离开去参加他的盛大
he just realized they might call him up to sing his signature song, Faith. Oh my gosh, I'm dressed as George Michael and they might call me up to sing Faith, come on. He's not prepared. Oh, he's not prepared at all. He hasn't even really thought that through. Jim is now gonna leave for his big Oh, he's not prepared at all. He hasn't even really thought that through.
会议，他再次与潘确认。你还是觉得我去投资很好。而她说，对，没错？是的。我们要这么做。既然要这么做，那就做吧。所以向大家分享这个场景的剧本与最终在这一集中播出的方式略有不同，这很重要。
Jim is now going to leave for his big meeting and he just double checks with Pam. You're still good that I'm going to invest. And she's like, yeah, right? Yeah. We're going to do this. If we're going to do it, let's do it. So it's important for me to share with everyone that this scene was scripted a little differently than how it ended up in the episode.
这将影响我们接下来的故事线。这个场景最初的剧本是这样的。潘说，快中午了，你不需要去把我们的积蓄炸出一个洞吗？这里有一点她愤怒的讽刺。吉姆说，没错，我知道我有一件事忘了做。然后他停顿了一下说，
And this is going to affect the storyline as we go on. The scene was originally scripted like this. Pam says, it's almost noon, don't you need to go blow a hole in our savings? There's a little of her angry sarcasm. And Jim says, that's right, I knew I was forgetting to do something. And then he pauses and he said,
而且这会影响到我们接下来的故事情节。这个场景最初的剧本是这样的。帕姆说，快中午了，你是不是该去把我们的积蓄挥霍一下了？这里带着她一点生气的讽刺。吉姆说，对哦，我知道我忘了一件事。然后他停顿了一下说，
was that an all in good fun thing? Or, and Pam says yes. And then Jim says, you sure you're cool with putting in 5,000. Yeah. And she says, yeah, I mean, if we're gonna do this thing, we should do it, right? And Jim says, you're the best.
这只是一件开玩笑的趣事吗？或者，帕姆说是的。然后吉姆说，你真的愿意投五千块吗？是的。然后她说，对啊，我是说，既然我们要这么做，就该好好做，对吧？吉姆说，你太棒了。
And Pam says, seriously, I am, it's crazy. So I just wanna say that in this story, Pam said that Jim could invest 5,000. Well, it's what they agreed on. Yes, they had a conversation. So later in the episode, when he puts in 10,000, that is again, not what they agreed on when they talked at home.
帕姆说，我是说真的，这太疯狂了。所以我只想说，在这段情节里，帕姆说过吉姆可以投资五千。嗯，这是他们商量好的。是的，他们聊过。所以后来在这一集里，当他投了一万块时，这再次与他们在家里谈话时商量好的不符。
And that is why Pam is going to get so mad. And I think it's kind of a bummer that that little tidbit got cut out, right? Because otherwise it just seems like Pam is angry that Jim did something that they agreed to. Right. But the truth is, the way it was originally written, he didn't. Right. As Jim leaves, Dwight is gonna hold up a little box of nerds candy.
这就是帕姆会那么生气的原因。我觉得这段小插曲被剪掉有点可惜，对吧？因为否则看起来就像帕姆在生吉姆的、他们本已同意做的事的气。没错。但事实是，按原本的剧本，他并没有这样做。没错。吉姆离开时，德怀特举起了一小盒老头乐（Nerd）糖果。
And he's like, look, I'm eating a gym. Get it, cause it's a nerd. Erin finds this hilarious. Yes. We had a fan question from Nick R in Peoria, Illinois, who said, Erin's loud laugh in this scene seemed to generate a genuine reaction for both her and Dwight.
他说，看，我在吃吉姆（Jim/Nerd谐音）。懂了吧，因为他是书呆子（Nerd）。艾琳觉得这 hilarious（太搞笑了）。是的。我们收到了来自伊利诺伊州皮奥里亚的尼克·R的粉丝提问，他说，艾琳在这个场景里的大笑，似乎让她和德怀特都做出了真实的反应。
Was it scripted or left in as a happy little accident? Either way, it's so great. Nick, it was scripted. It says Dwight says, Jim is a nerd, this is a box of gyms, and Aaron laughs, and then it says in all caps, really loud and covers her mouth. And then it says Aaron keeps laughing, keeps laughing, until she has to run towards the bathroom.
这是剧本写好的，还是作为一个幸福的小意外保留下来的？不管怎样，真的很棒。尼克，这是剧本写好的。上面写着，德怀特说，吉姆是个书呆子，这是一盒吉姆，然后艾琳笑了，接着大写字母写着：声音很大并捂住了嘴。然后写着，艾琳一直在笑，一直在笑，直到她不得不跑向卫生间。
Well, we also had a fan question from Barb B. in Wisconsin who said, when Dwight makes Erin laugh so hard, she has to pee. Was this a nod to the work bus episode when Ellie as Erin actually peed from laughing so hard? I wondered that. I did too. I mean, it had literally just happened.
嗯，我们还收到了威斯康星州巴比·B的粉丝提问，她说，当德怀特把艾琳逗得大笑，以至于她不得不去小便时，这是否是在致敬《工作大巴》那一集里，作为艾琳的埃莉真的笑到尿裤子？我也纳思过。我也是。我的意思是，这刚发生过。
This episode comes right after work bus. Yes. And we all had this collective story. I feel like it must have. I know. Well, Ellie was a good sport about all of it, so no doubt she was like fine with it. Well Dwight drops a bunch of gyms on the ground. He's picking them up and while doing so he finds a little yellow pill.
这一集就在《工作大巴》之后。是的。我们都有过这种共同的经历。我觉得它一定是的。我知道。好吧，埃莉对这一切都很开朗，所以毫无疑问她觉得这没问题。接着德怀特把一地吉姆糖洒了。他正在捡，在这个过程中他发现了一颗黄色的小药丸。
Yeah. He has a talking head where he says, It's Dumatrill. It treats anxiety symptoms such as panic attacks, excessive worrying and fear. Translation, there's a madman in our midst. This is now going to be his storyline for the rest of the episode. He has got to find out whose pill this is. He's gonna mom detective it. Yes. FYI, Duma troll does not exist. It's made up. It's a made up. Yeah. Mm-hmm. We now see
是的。他有一个采访镜头，说道：“这是杜马崔（Dumatrill）。它治疗焦虑症状，如恐慌发作、过度担忧和恐惧。翻译一下：我们中间出了个疯子。”这现在成了他接下来这一集的主线任务。他必须查出这颗药丸是谁的。他要像妈妈侦探一样去查个水落石出。是的。顺便说一句，杜马崔并不存在。是编造的。是编造的。是的。嗯哼。我们现在看到
Nelly. She is dressed as sexy Toby and she shares in a talking head that the anxiety pill is hers. She's not ashamed of it but she doesn't love the idea of Dwight having that information about her since he once yelled at Phyllis for sneezing wrong. Nellie agrees with Dwight that, you know, the person who owns this pill needs to be apprehended. So Dwight is gonna go get his apprehension kit. Yeah. And now he's got a partner to help solve this mystery. Lady, do we need an apprehension kit for mom detectives in case we have to apprehend someone?
奈莉。她打扮成性感的托比，并在采访镜头里分享说这颗焦虑药丸是她的。她对此并不感到羞耻，但她不太喜欢德怀特掌握了关于她的这个信息，因为他曾经对着菲利斯乱打喷嚏大吼大叫。奈莉同意德怀特的看法，你知道的，拥有这颗药丸的人必须被缉拿归案。所以德怀特要去拿他的缉拿工具包了。是的。现在他有了一个搭档来帮他解开这个谜团。女士，妈妈侦探们需要缉拿工具包吗，以防我们需要去抓人？
Or if we have to go on a stakeout, like I feel like it would all be in the same kit. We need snacks and water. Flashlight? Flashlight's good. I think we should have the ones that go on our heads so that we can be handspray. Oh, yes, yes.
或者如果我们必须去盯梢，我觉得这些东西都会放在同一个工具包里。我们需要零食和水。手电筒？手电筒不错。我觉得我们应该准备那种戴在头上的，这样我们可以解放双手。哦，对，对。
Headlamp. Headlamp. Snacks, a blanket, I'll be cold. Yeah. Megaphone? Smart. Megaphone. Yes. Yeah. Rather than sneak up, let's go in hot. Be like, we see you. Yeah. We should get one of those things that makes things bigger. A magnifying glass? Yes. Yes. Yes. In case we have to look at tiny evidence. Yes. We'll all be tiny for us for the most part. Lady, I have another case.
头灯。头灯。零食、毯子，我会冷。是的。扩音器？聪明。扩音器。是的。对。与其潜伏靠近，不如大摇大摆地进去。就说：我们看到你了。是的。我们应该弄一个能把东西放大的东西。放大镜？是的。是的。是的。以防我们得观察微小的证据。对。对我们来说基本上都会很小。女士，我还有另一个案子。
What? In your neighborhood? In my neighborhood. Okay. So I walk Maggie in the neighborhood and someone keeps taking their like plastic water bottles or their used coffee cups. And they either like stick them in some bushes, like someone's bushes, or they put them on top of the little library. Oh, so it's just, that's not cool. I know. And I want to stake it out. Okay.
什么？在你附近？在我附近。好吧。所以我带玛吉在社区散步时，有人一直把他们的塑料水瓶或用过的咖啡杯。要么塞进某些灌木丛里，比如某人的灌木丛，要么放在小图书馆的顶部。哦，所以这就，这太缺德了。我知道。我想去盯梢。好吧。
See if we can figure out who's doing it. Is it multiple people? I don't get it. No. Oh, you know what I just realized? What? I took a picture of it in the bushes. I was going to send it to you.
看能不能搞清楚是谁干的。是多个人吗？我不懂。不。哦，你知道我刚意识到什么吗？什么？我拍下了它在灌木丛里的照片。我正打算发给你呢。
I took a picture of it on top of the little library. One of them was a Starbucks cup. It would be so easy. We could at least get a first name. Oh, good point. Next time it happens. Maybe. Look at me already solving the case. In our apprehension kit, we could have like some silly putty. What's that for? You can can't you get a fingerprint off with silly putty? Off of the cup? Yeah.
我拍下了它在小图书馆顶部的照片。其中一个是星巴克杯子。这太容易了。我们至少能知道一个名字。哦，好主意。下次发生时。也许吧。看我都已经在破案了。在我们的缉拿工具包里，我们可以放点橡皮泥。那是用来干嘛的？你不是可以用橡皮泥提取指纹吗？从杯子上？对。
Well, what do we do with it after we get it? Who's running that fingerprint? Who do you see in your silly buddy fingerprint too? I mean, good idea, but where do we go with that? It doesn't really help us. It doesn't really help us. Listen, we'll figure it out. We'll figure it out. And when we see the person, we're just going to- We have the megaphone. We have the megaphone to be like, stop leaving your trash in the bushes. Yeah. By the way, I want to say this is coming full circle. Maybe we'll hide in the bushes and pop out of them.
那我们拿到之后该怎么办？谁去查这个指纹？你觉得你的橡皮泥指纹能查出谁来？我的意思是，主意不错，但我们拿着它去哪？这其实帮不了我们。这真的帮不了我们。听着，我们会想出办法的。我们会想出办法的。当我们看到那个人时，我们就——我们有扩音器。我们有扩音器可以说：别把垃圾丢在灌木丛里。是的。顺便说一句，我想说这形成了一个完整的闭环。也许我们会躲在灌木丛里然后突然跳出来。
We'll be bush hiders again. Oh yeah. Right? Oh, you know what would be so great? What? Is if when they put the water bottle in the bush, a hand just came out. Yes!
我们又可以当灌木丛躲藏者了。哦，对。对吧？哦，你知道什么会很棒吗？什么？就是当他们把水瓶扔进灌木丛时，突然伸出了一只手。太棒了！
What if they threw it back at them? Throw them back, yes. All right, I think we have a plan. Well, we have something. Well, lady, if we ever have some extra time and we wanna take that case, I already have some photographic evidence for us, so. Okay, step one, done.
如果他们把它扔回给对方呢？扔回去，对。好吧，我觉得我们有个计划。好吧，我们总算有点东西了。好吧，女士，如果我们以后有空想接那个案子，我已经为我们准备好了一些照片证据，所以。好吧，第一步，完成。
Step two is five at the time. Well, let's take a break and when we come back, we're gonna find out how Andy got the nickname Boner Champ. Yeah, it's not how I thought. No, it's not how anyone would think. We'll be back. We are back. Andy is gonna go join. Here comes comes trouble hanging out in the break room.
第二步是……好吧，我们休息一下，回来后，我们将揭晓安迪是怎么得到“勃起大王”（Boner Champ）这个外号的。是的，不是我想的那样。不，这不是任何人能想到的。我们马上回来。我们回来了。安迪要加入……麻烦制造者合唱团在休息室里闲逛。
Before Andy is hanging out in the break room, I wanted to share with you guys some of these college a cappella names I found. They all have puns. There are hundreds. I'm just going to share a few. Ready? Yes. Pitch slapped. Okay. get it. I got it. Berkeley College of Music. Ransom Notes. University of Chicago. Sexy Pitches. Alfred University. Shirley Tempose.
在安迪去休息室闲逛之前，我想和大家分享一些我找到的大学阿卡贝拉（无伴奏合唱）团的名字。它们都有双关语。有几百个。我只分享几个。准备好了吗？好的。Pitch slapped（音高耳光）。好吧。懂了。我懂了。伯克利音乐学院。Ransom Notes（勒索信/赎金音符）。芝加哥大学。Sexy Pitches（性感音高/音准）。阿尔弗雷德大学。Shirley Tempose（秀兰·邓波儿/秀兰·节奏）。
Hmm. Brandeis University. Noteworthy. Bringham Young University. Seductaves. Get it octaves, but they're seductaves. University of Florida. Interchorus. Oh, I know. St. Mary's College of Maryland.
嗯。布兰迪斯大学。Noteworthy（值得注意的/音符）。杨百翰大学。Seductaves（诱惑音符/八度音阶谐音）。懂的，octaves（八度），但他们是 seductaves（诱惑八度）。佛罗里达大学。Interchorus（合唱之间）。哦，我知道。马里兰州圣玛丽学院。
Treble Threat. University of San Diego. So a pun is like a prerequisite for being an acapella group name? Not necessarily, but it is definitely very popular. Well, I got curious. What is the oldest acapella group? What is it? According to Wikipedia, Peter Lutkin, the Dean of Northwestern University School of Music, founded the Northwestern
Treble Threat（高音威胁）。圣迭戈大学。所以双关语就像是成为一个阿卡贝拉团队名字的先决条件？不一定，但它确实非常受欢迎。好吧，我很好奇。最古老的阿卡贝拉团队是什么？是什么？根据维基百科，西北大学音乐学院院长彼得·鲁特金（Peter Lutkin）于1906年创立了西北
Acapella Choir in 1906, and it is considered the first permanent acapella group of its kind in America. However, the continuously longest running group is thought to be the Wiffenpuffs of Yale, which formed in 1909. I'm telling you, the names are fascinating. No pun in Wiffen Poofs of Yale, which formed in 1909. I'm telling you, the names are fascinating. No pun in Wiffen Poofs. No. Andy's gonna have a talking head and he's gonna say,
阿卡贝拉合唱团，它被认为是美国同类中第一个永久性的阿卡贝拉团队。然而，人们认为持续运营时间最长的团队是耶鲁大学的威芬普夫斯（Wiffenpuffs），成立于1909年。我跟你说，这些名字太迷人了。耶鲁的威芬普夫斯可没有双关语。我跟你说，这些名字太迷人了。威芬普夫斯没有双关语。没有。安迪会有一个采访镜头，他会说：
you know, I know it's pathetic to relive your college years, but I was a fricking rock star in college. Yeah. When I joined Here Comes Trouble, when he got the name Boner Champ, that's when he became himself. Yeah. Yeah. Andy's gonna ask that Here Comes Trouble guys if they wanna, that's when he became himself. Yeah. Yeah.
你知道的，我知道重温大学时光很可悲，但我大学时是个绝对的摇滚巨星。是的。当我加入麻烦制造者合唱团时，当我得到“勃起大王”这个外号时，那就是他真正做自己的时刻。是的。是的。安迪要问那几个麻烦制造者合唱团的伙计们，他们想不想……那就是他真正做自己的时刻。是的。是的。
Andy's gonna ask that here comes trouble guys if they wanna, you know, do a Q&A. Little question and answer. It's apparent very quickly that they don't even realize he was in the group. Broccoli Rob is rewriting history. They didn't even know he was the Boner Champ. Andy is so ticked off. He like storms out of the room. When he realizes that they didn't know
安迪要问那几个麻烦制造者合唱团的伙计们，他们想不想，你知道的，搞个问答环节。一个小小的问答。很明显，他们甚至没意识到他曾加入过这个团队。西兰花罗布（Broccoli Rob）正在篡改历史。他们甚至不知道他是勃起大王。安迪气炸了。他气冲冲地跑出了房间。当他意识到他们并不知道
he was the boner champ, I loved Ed's performance so much. Ed is so good in this whole episode. So good. I did want to point out, did anyone else out there catch how squeaky Andy's jacket is? Yes, I did. Every every scene it makes noise.
他是勃起大王时，我太喜欢埃德（Ed）的表演了。埃德整集都演得太好了。太棒了。我本来想指出，有没有其他人注意到安迪的夹克有多吱呀作响？是的，我注意到了。每一个场景它都在发出噪音。
Oh my gosh, the sound department must have been dying. So I'll have you know a few of the guys speak. But there was one member of this Here Comes Treble acapella group who was not a member of the Hullabahoos. That's right. And this was actor Daniel Ammerman. They did feel it was important that we cast an actor from this group who would kind of have maybe the bulk of the lines.
天哪，音效部门当时一定快急死了。所以我要告诉你们，其中几个家伙确实开口说话了。但这个麻烦制造者阿卡贝拉团里有一个成员，他其实并不是“喧嚣合唱团”（Hullabahoos）的成员。没错。这就是演员丹尼尔·阿默曼（Daniel Ammerman）。他们确实觉得找一个这个团队的演员来演台词最多的角色很重要。
We'll see him again in the conference room. And he's done a ton of stuff. He had a big recurring role on Arrested Development. He can also sing. He had a guest star role on Glee. And he just had to show up. He was the one member of this group and he had to rehearse with them and sing along with them and just sort of became an honorary hullabahoo for the week. Well, I will let you know on the call sheets, they were having daily rehearsals over in the warehouse. I remember that, don't you? I went over to the warehouse to watch them rehearse. Yeah.
我们会在会议室里再次看到他。他演过海量的作品。他在《发展受阻》里有一个重要的常驻角色。他还会唱歌。他在《欢乐合唱团》里客串过。他只需要出现就行了。他是这个团队的唯一成员，他不得不和他们一起排练、一起唱歌，在这一周里不知不觉成了荣誉团员。好吧，我告诉你们，通告单上写着，他们每天都在仓库里排练。我记得，对吧？我去了仓库看他们排练。是的。
Well, Andy is going to video call Broccoli Rob. Yeah, he wants to get to the bottom of this boner champ thing. Yeah. And Broccoli Rob is gaslighting him appropriately and he's like, I just don't know how that could have happened. Yeah. I don't know.
好吧，安迪要跟西兰花罗布进行视频通话。是的，他想弄清这个“勃起大王”外号的来龙去脉。是的。而西兰花罗布正在完美地对进行精神控制（gaslighting），他说，我只是不知道这怎么会发生。是的。我不知道。
Wine coolers were flowing. Yeah. I was just, you know, talking about the old days. Well, Andy says I would like you to call the guys and set the record straight. It's very important. Broccoli Rob says, sure like you to call the guys and set the record straight. It's very important. Mm-hmm. Broccoli Robb says, sure.
葡萄酒酷派饮料一杯接一杯。是的。我只是，你知道的，在谈论过去的旧时光。好吧，安迪说，我希望你给那些家伙打电话，以正视听。这非常重要。西兰花罗布说，我希望你给那些家伙打电话，以正视听。这非常重要。嗯哼。西兰花罗布说，没问题。
No problem. I'd be happy to do that. Meanwhile, Pete is standing with his coworkers. He's the only person not in costume. He tells Creed, I didn't realize that everyone dressed up. Creed splattered in blood says, I didn't either. Yeah. I looked in the shooting draft
我很高兴这么做。与此同时，皮ート（Pete）正和同事们站在一起。他是唯一一个没有穿万圣节服装的人。他告诉科瑞德（Creed），我没意识到大家都盛装打扮了。浑身溅满血迹的科瑞德说，我也没意识到。是的。我查阅了拍摄剧本
for what it said about Creed's costume. It just says this, Creed is dressed normally but covered in blood. Yeah. Creed has a talking head. He said it's Halloween. Wow, that's really good timing. Yeah.
关于科瑞德服装的描述。上面只写了这些：科瑞德穿着正常，但浑身是血。是的。科瑞德有一个采访镜头。他说：今天是万圣节。哇，这时间掐得真准。
I mean, was he gonna come to work like that? I know. What the hell? Never explained himself. Yeah, I know. Next up is a scene where Jim is gonna cause some problems in his marriage. Yeah, he is. He's just gonna go all in.
我的意思是，他原本打算那样去上班吗？我知道。搞什么鬼？从来不解释自己。是的，我知道。接下来是一个场景，吉姆将在他的婚姻中制造一些麻烦。是的，他会的。他打算直接全押。
He's gonna offer the full 10K. They welcome him aboard. I would like to shout out one of the athlete investors, Sam Richardson. Sam, yes! Yes! He ends up doing a big arc on the show. We're gonna see him for six episodes. That's right.
他要主动提出投资满额的1万块。他们欢迎他加入。我要大声感谢其中一位演员投资者萨姆·理查森（Sam Richardson）。萨姆，太棒了！是的！他最终在剧中有了一条重要的大故事线。我们会看到他演六集。没错。
He plays Colin, Jim's buddy. Sam is so funny, you guys. I was lucky enough to work with him in a little indie movie about girl softball called All Stars, but he's been in two of my favorite shows. Veep and The After Party? Ted Lasso. Oh, and After Party. Yes, okay. Well, we were really! And after party, yes, okay.
他饰演科林（Colin），吉姆的好友。萨姆太搞笑了，伙计们。我很幸运能和他在一部关于女子垒球的小独立电影《全明星》中合作，但他演过我最喜欢的两部剧。《副总统》和《After Party》（人生切割术/隔壁好莱坞/最后一次狂欢）？《足球教练》（Ted Lasso）。哦，还有《After Party》。对，没错。好吧，我们真是！还有《After Party》，对，没错。
Well, we were really lucky to have Sam and I'm so excited that his character is gonna come back for a few more episodes. And I wanna reach out to him. I wanna hear about his time on the show. I would love that. Sam, get ready. One thing I think we should point out
好吧，我们真的很幸运能请到萨姆，我很高兴他的角色会在接下来的几集里回归。我想联系他。我想听听他在剧组的时光。我太乐意了。萨姆，准备好。我觉得有一点我们应该指出
during this meeting is that the investors tell Jim they have all the money they need. Yeah. We don't need your investment. And he's like, but maybe I want to invest. I feel like Jim is so worried that he's going to get left out of his own idea that he's just like, I got to make sure that I'm fully equal here. Yeah.
在这场会议期间，投资者告诉吉姆他们已经有了需要的所有资金。是的。我们不需要你的投资。而他说，但也许我想投资。我觉得吉姆太担心自己会被排除在自己的创意之外，以至于他只是觉得：我得确保在这里拥有完全平等的地位。是的。
And he starts by floating 5,000 maybe 10? Because 5,000 is what he and Pam had talked about. Yes. So I just want you to know that this little story beat was a pitch of mine. I found my old pitch notes, my emails to everybody, and I had written that when Jim shows up to lunch, that the guys should say,
他一开始试探性地投个5000，也许10000？因为5000是他和帕姆商量好的金额。是的。所以我只是想让你们知道，这个小剧情是我提出来的。我找到了我以前的提案笔记、给所有人的电子邮件，我写过当吉姆出现在午餐时，那些家伙应该说：
you don't have to put any money in, blah, blah, blah, but then Jim showboats and invests more than they agreed on. He invests 10,000. Well, I like it. I thought it showed sort of how desperate Jim is to make this happen. Mm-hmm. Nellie and Dwight are still on the case of the search for this anxiety pill owner. They find Darryl in the kitchen and I guess Dw Dwight is gonna smear his whole face with peanut butter, and if this seems like normal, appropriate behavior to Darrell, then he's gotta be the person with the pill.
你不用出钱，等等等等，但随后吉姆爱出风头，投资了超过他们商定金额的钱。他投资了1万块。好吧，我喜欢这样。我觉得这展现了吉姆为了让这件事成真有多么迫切。嗯哼。奈莉和德怀特仍在寻找这颗焦虑药丸的主人。他们在厨房找到了达里尔（Darryl），我猜德怀特要把他的整张脸抹上花生酱，如果达里尔觉得这是正常、得体的行为，那他肯定就是那个有药丸的人。
Claire sent us a very funny photo from OnSet. Behind the scenes photo of this. Yes, of rain with all of the peanut butter on his face. It was so much. It was a lot. It was a lot. So now Andy's gonna go back, he's gonna revisit the
克莱尔给我们发了一张片场非常搞笑的照片。幕后花絮照。是的，雷恩（Rainn）满脸都是花生酱。真的有好多。有很多。真的超级多。现在安迪要回去了，他要再次去找
acapella guys. And guess what? Broccoli Rob did set the record straight. Yeah. But Andy is like, you probably want to know how I got the name Boner Champ, right? Like you're dying to know. You want me to tell you? Spring Sing 95. We got completely ripped on Bud Drys. I had sex with a snowman. You guys, the room turns. The room turns. Andy is so proud of this memory. I did look it up according to the internet. What did you look up?
那几个阿卡贝拉的家伙。你猜怎么着？西兰花罗布确实以正视听了。是的。但安迪却说：你们可能想知道我是怎么得到“勃起大王”这个外号的，对吧？就像你们渴望知道一样。想让我告诉你们吗？95年的春季歌唱大赛。我们喝巴德干啤（Bud Drys）喝得烂醉如泥。我和一个雪人发生了性关系。伙计们，全场气氛变了。全场气氛变了。安迪为这段记忆感到无比骄傲。我确实根据互联网查了一下。你查了什么？
Well, I was just curious about how a man's business might work if it's that cold. What'd you find out? It says this, the body tries to preserve heat and energy by funneling blood flow to vital organs in the middle of the body. Getting erections is also more challenging as the cold desensitizes the penis, which becomes less responsive to stimulation. Cold weather can even cause men to take longer to get an orgasm. So this is really impressive that Andy was able to do this, I guess.
嗯，我只是好奇如果天气那么冷，一个男人的小弟弟会怎么运作。你查到了什么？上面是这么写的：身体试图通过将血液引导至身体中部的生命器官来保存热量和能量。勃起也更具挑战性，因为寒冷会使阴茎麻木，从而对刺激的反应降低。寒冷天气甚至会导致男性达到高潮的时间更长。所以安迪能做到这一点真的很impressive（让人印象深刻），我猜。
I guess that's why he's so proud. Yeah. Well, if you thought that this storyline was crazy, writer Owen Ellickson had a different pitch for this episode that is even more crazy. Then Bonerchamp and the Snowman? Yeah. What? Owen was quoted in Andy Green's book about the office saying that early in the pitches for this episode, it was going to be, Andy was going to host his Here Comes Treble alumni.
我想这就是他为什么这么骄傲吧。是的。好吧，如果你觉得这个剧情已经够疯狂了，编剧欧文·埃里克森（Owen Ellickson）为这一集准备的另一个提案甚至更加疯狂。比勃起大王和雪人还疯狂？是的。什么？安迪·格林（Andy Green）关于《办公室》的书里引用了欧文的话，说在这一集早期的构思中，原本的情节是：安迪要接待他的麻烦制造者合唱团校友。
So all the guys like Broccoli Rob was going to actually come into the office and that they were going to sing and all of that sort of thing. And that they would start talking about, you know, the good old days back in school, and the guys were going to talk about one of the members who had died in the group. And it was going to slowly become clear to Andy that the guys in the group, including himself, had actually killed this other member, and they had covered it up all these years, basically that Andy was part of like a murder silence pact. Oh my gosh.
所以就像西兰花罗布这样的所有家伙都要来到办公室，他们会唱歌等等。然后他们开始谈论，你知道的，当年在学校的美好旧时光，然后这些家伙开始谈论团里一个已经去世的成员。接着安迪会慢慢明白，团里的这些家伙，包括他自己，实际上杀害了这位成员，而且他们这些年来一直在掩盖真相，基本上就是安迪参与了一个谋杀缄口契约。哦天哪。
I know, because it was also because it was like a Halloween theme episode, right? Right, right. So there was gonna be this murder thing, Andy was gonna realize. Owens said he was really just trying to find a way to differentiate Andy from Michael, and he was like, well, that said he was really just trying to find a way to differentiate Andy from Michael. And he was like, well, that's something Michael's never done, you know, Michael's never killed a guy and covered up a murder.
我知道，因为这也因为它是一个万圣节主题剧集，对吧？对，对。所以原本会有这样一个谋杀案，安迪会意识到。欧文说他其实只是想找一种方法把安迪和迈克尔区分开来，他说，嗯，他说他其实只是想找一种方法把安迪和迈克尔区分开来。他说，嗯，这是迈克尔从未做过的事，你知道的，迈克尔从未杀过人并掩盖谋杀案。
And then Owen said, we obviously cut this idea. We went with Halstead's idea instead. And years later, it became Yellowjacket. Yes, exactly. Angela is now going to bring the senator in. He is wearing a Ronald Reagan mask, and she reintroduces him to Oscar and then sees that the food table is all messed up. The desserts aren't where they're supposed to be. The sweets are with the savories.
然后欧文说，我们显然删掉了这个想法。我们最后改用了霍尔斯特德（Halstead）的主意。多年以后，这成了《黄蜂网》（Yellowjacket）。是的，完全如此。安吉拉现在要把参议员带进来了。他戴着罗纳德·里根的面具，她把他重新介绍给奥斯卡（Oscar），然后发现食物桌一团糟。甜点没有放在应该放的地方。甜食和开胃小菜混在一起了。
I know, and she is so ticked off at Phyllis. And she's like, I'm sorry, I have to go talk to Phyllis. Well, this scene was longer. Angela does find Phyllis. They have it out, but all in the background, the senator and Oscar are flirting. I want you to hear the scene. Brownies and ginger snaps on the same plate. Where was the logic there? I mean, what was going through your mind? I just thought it was a party and people wouldn't think too much about it.
我知道，她对菲利斯气炸了。她说：对不起，我得去跟菲利斯谈谈。好吧，这个场景本来更长。安吉拉确实找到了菲利斯。她们大吵了一架，但在背景里，参议员和奥斯卡正在调情。我想让你们听听这个场景。布朗尼蛋糕和姜饼干放在同一个盘子里。那里的逻辑在哪里？我是说，你脑子里在想什么？我只是觉得这是个派对，大家不会太在意这些。
Ridiculous. You know, this is what happens when I give you a long leash but you are not getting within a mile of the snacks table for the Christmas party. Yeah I understand. I feel bad about this. Good. Maybe the cupcakes with the ginger snaps. No nothing should be with the ginger snaps. Ginger snaps are off putting to some people. What's your favorite? Maybe you shouldn't be in charge of arranging the snacks. Don't go there, sweetie. Don't you go there. Do your job. Phyllis goes, don't you go there, sweetie?
荒谬。你知道的，这就是我给你太大自由的结果，但圣诞派对的零食桌你方圆一英里内都别想靠近。是的，我明白。对此我很抱歉。很好。也许该把纸杯蛋糕和姜饼干放一起。不，什么都不能和姜饼干放一起。姜饼干对有些人来说很扫兴。你最喜欢哪个？也许你不该负责安排零食。别扯到那儿去，亲爱的。你少来这套。做好你的工作。菲利斯说：你少来这套，亲爱的？
And then under her breath, Angela says, do your job. It is so layered with tension. And you know what? If you get a sweetie out of Phyllis, get ready. Yeah. She's about to throw down. Erin is trying to make Andy feel better about the group, not really maybe being super excited about his Boner Champ story.
然后安吉拉小声嘀咕道：做好你的工作。这充满了紧张感。你知道吗？如果你能从菲利斯那里听到一句“亲爱的”，那就准备好吧。是的。她要发飙了。埃琳正试图让安迪对这个团队没有对他的“勃起大王”故事表现得超级兴奋这件事感觉好一点。
Erin is like, what is wrong with these turkeys? Yeah, she marches into the break room and says, hey, you have to sing faith. Learn it. Yeah, she marches into the break room and says, hey, you have to sing faith. Learn it. Yeah. Just do it. And the guy's like, but, but she goes, butts are for pooping. Make it work. And make it a surprise. Meanwhile Dwight and Nelly are camped out in the kitchen. The pill is on a plate on the counter and they're doing a stakeout, lady. I know. Toby is gonna enter the stakeout, and he sees Nelly in her costume, and he recognizes himself.
埃琳就像是在说：这群火鸡是怎么回事？是的，她气势汹汹地走进休息室说：嘿，你们得唱《Faith》（信念）。学会它。是的，她气势汹汹地走进休息室说：嘿，你们得唱《Faith》。学会它。是的。直接唱。那些家伙说：可是，可是……她说：可是是用来拉屎的。把它搞定。还要制造一个惊喜。与此同时，德怀特和奈莉在厨房里驻扎盯梢。药丸放在柜台的盘子上，他们在进行盯梢，女士。我知道。托比走进了盯梢现场，他看到穿着戏服的奈莉，认出了她扮演的是自己。
He seems very transfixed. I was curious what the shooting draft had to say about this moment, so I looked it up. What does it say? Per the shooting draft, it says, Toby enters, Nelly nods at him, Toby looks at her with embarrassment, then anger, then lust. He briefly moves towards her as if to kiss her, then hurries out.
他看起来十分着迷。我很想知道拍摄剧本对这一刻是怎么写的，所以我查了一下。上面写了什么？根据拍摄剧本，上面写着：托比走进来，奈莉向他点头，托比看着她，先是尴尬，然后是愤怒，最后是色迷迷。他短暂地朝她走去，仿佛要亲吻她，然后匆忙离开。
Hmm. It's a lot happening in that moment. Yeah. A lot of, I guess, self-loathing and then self-love from Toby. Yeah. I thought it was weird. I know, I did too. I didn't get it. I didn't get it. Guess who's gonna come in and try to claim that pill? Meredith. She sees it as a free upper. And Dwight is gonna net her. He gets out a giant net. Is this something we need for our stakeout bag? I guess so.
嗯。那一刻发生了好多事。是的。托比内心有大量的，我猜是自我厌恶，然后又是自恋。是的。我觉得这很诡异。我知道，我也是。我不理解。我真的不懂。你猜谁会走进来并试图认领那颗药丸？梅雷迪思。她把它看作是一片免费的兴奋剂。德怀特要用网兜住她。他拿出了一个巨大的网兜。这是我们盯梢包里需要的东西吗？我想是的。
What could you imagine if we netted the guy who's- Or a raccoon. You think a raccoon is putting the bottles in the bushes? No, but if we go digging in the bushes, we're gonna find a varmint. A varmint? That's what my mom says. She'll be like, there's varmints out there.
你能想象如果我们用网兜住那个——或者一只浣熊。你觉得是浣熊把瓶子扔进灌木丛的吗？不，但如果我们去灌木丛里翻找，我们会找到一只害兽。害兽？我妈就是这么说的。她会说：外面有害兽。
It is a thick bush. Oh lord. There are so many in this episode. I can't even that's what she said all of them. Wow. Kate has one of her famous lines in this episode where she says to Dwight, stop bagging my head. Yes, this is the second time he's bagged her. He had to bag her when she had the bat on her head and now he's bagging her again. Listen to you, lady. Listen, I know what you're doing. I'm not doing anything. It's a callback to a previous episode. A previous episode. Yes. I think it's time for I Get to Know Your Cast and Crew. Thanks to the call sheets. Who are we going to learn about today?
这是一个茂密的灌木丛。哦天呐。这一集里有太多双关了。我甚至……她就是这么说的，全都有。哇。凯特在这一集里有一句她的名言，她对德怀特说：别再往我头上套袋子了。是的，这是他第二次给她套袋子了。之前蝙蝠趴在她头上时他得给她套袋子，现在他又给她套袋子了。听听你说的，女士。听着，我知道你在干嘛。我什么都没干。这是对之前某一集的致敬。前一集。是的。我想是时候进行“了解你的演员和剧组”环节了。感谢通告单。我们今天要了解谁？
Nick Carbone. Hey, Nick Carbone, my favorite boom operator of all boom operators. That's right. It says Nick loves music, exclamation point. In parentheses, like you didn't know that. His love of music came from his father who took him to a Janice Joplin concert when he was 8 years old. The house that he grew up in is next door to where Ben currently lives, Ben, our sound designer. This is how they met.
尼克·卡博恩（Nick Carbone）。嘿，尼克·卡博恩，我所有收音师中最喜欢的收音师。没错。上面写着，尼克热爱音乐，感叹号。括号里写着：就像你不知道似的。他对音乐的热爱来自他的父亲，在他8岁时带他去听了一场贾尼斯·乔普林（Janis Joplin）的演唱会。他长大的房子隔壁就是本（Ben）目前住的地方，本是我们的音效设计师。他们就是这样认识的。
One of his first shows was the classic Golden Girls, and that's where he met Kent Sabornak. Wow. There you go. Well, now we're in the conference room and everyone is seated. They are ready for this acapella concert. We did get a fan catch from Alice in H in Louisville, Kentucky, who said, did they really clear out all of the conference room chairs for the party and then move all the food out and put all the chairs back in for the acapella concert? This would really be a great opportunity for the B-roll we never see
他的第一批节目之一是经典美剧《黄金女郎》，正是在那里他遇到了肯·萨博纳克（Kent Sabornak）。哇。就是这样。好吧，现在我们在会议室里，大家都坐好了。他们准备好欣赏这场阿卡贝拉音乐会了。我们确实收到了来自肯塔基州路易斯维尔的爱丽丝·H的粉丝抓包，她说：他们真的把会议室里的所有椅子都清空来办派对，然后把所有的食物都搬出去，又把所有的椅子搬回来办阿卡贝拉音乐会吗？这绝对是展示我们从未看到的幕后花絮的绝佳机会
of people moving the tables and chairs in and out of the conference room. Alice, you were reading from my personal journal because I wrote, gonna play a bulls*** Card Here. Where's all the table of desserts? Where'd it all go? Who moved it? This is when Jim is going to get back from his lunch. He's going to have a seat next to Pam.
关于人们把桌椅搬进搬出会议室。爱丽丝，你简直是在读我个人的日记，因为我当时写的是：我要在这里打出“胡扯”牌。甜点桌都去哪了？都去哪了？谁把它搬走的？这就是吉姆结束午餐回来的时候。他在帕姆旁边坐了下来。
Pam wants to know how to go, how to go. He just very quickly is able to say that he pledged the full 10,000. Yeah. You know, he says they said they were good on investing, but you know, he says they said they were good on investing, but you know, he still went all in. Pam is having an out-of-body experience. She's like, wait, what? What? $10,000? And they did, like, she's processing all of it. Yeah. Right as the acapella group starts to sing and she's being serenaded and pulled into the circle, they roll her chair.
帕姆想知道进展如何，进展如何。他非常简短地表示他认捐了满额的1万块。是的。你知道，他说他们说投资额已经足够了，你知道，他说他们说投资额已经足够了，但他还是全押了。帕姆正在经历灵魂出窍。她像是：等等，什么？什么？1万美元？然后他们做了，就像，她在消化这一切。是的。就在阿卡贝拉合唱团开始唱歌、她被情歌深情款款地包围并拉进圈子里时，他们转动了她的椅子。
While Jim and Pam are having this fight, I thought we should hear it. They said they were done with the investing and then you volunteered $10,000. I know I had to, look, I need to look like a team player, be able to. So you invested $10,000 to look like a team player? And I'll be your crying shoulder.
在吉姆和帕姆吵架的时候，我觉得我们应该听听这段。他们说投资已经结束了，然后你主动资助了1万美元？我知道我必须这么做，听着，我需要让自己看起来像个团队合作者，能够……所以你投资了1万美元就是为了看起来像个团队合作者？而我将是你哭泣时的肩膀。
I'll be love suicide. And I'll be better when I'm older. I'll be the greatest man of your life. Ah, this is a really big fight. And it's playing out underneath this acapella song. But you hear PMC, wait, that's all of our savings. First of all, I want to say I'm very impressed that as a newly married couple with two young children,
我将成为你爱的殉道者。我年长时会变得更好。我将成为你生命中最伟大的男人。啊，这是一场非常大的争吵。而且它是在这首阿卡贝拉歌曲的伴奏下进行的。但你听到帕姆说：等等，那是我们所有的积蓄。首先，我想说我很佩服作为一对育有两个幼儿的新婚夫妇，
that they have saved $10,000. Well done, guys. They clearly, you know. I've been working at that. This is something, you know, that doesn't happen by itself. And so now it's all gone. It's gone.
他们居然存下了1万美元。干得好，伙计们。他们显然，你知道的。一直在努力。这不是凭空发生的。结果现在全没了。全没了。
This scene was so much fun to shoot. I absolutely loved being serenaded. It was very hard for me to stay angry. This is very similar to early in the show when I'm being serenaded by Andy on the banjo, but I'm supposed to act like I'm annoyed when I love the banjo. So this was very funny. Well, Nick Caferro shared about this moment in singing to you. Here's what he had to say.
拍摄这场戏太有趣了。我绝对热爱被深情歌唱。要保持生气真的很难。这和我早期在剧中被安迪用班卓琴深情歌唱、但我却得假装很烦恼（其实我很喜欢班卓琴）时非常像。所以这太搞笑了。好吧，尼克·卡费罗（Nick Caferro）分享了关于这一刻对你唱歌的感受。他是这么说的：
One of the scenes that we did, my biggest scene was I had to sing All Be to Jenna. And the first thing was the conference room was so small. It was so tiny. I mean, I'm used to seeing it on TV and I thought it was huge. But to be in there with all of you staring at me was terrifying. You were like literally, and I'm not just, again, not just saying this because I'm here.
我们拍的其中一个场景，我戏份最多的一场是我必须对珍娜唱《I'll Be》（我会的）。首先是会议室太小了。太迷你了。我是说，我习惯了在电视上看到它，我以为它很大。但跟你们所有人都盯着我看简直太吓人了。你们简直是字面意义上的，我不是，再次强调，不是因为我在这里才这么说。
You were all my favorite act. This was my favorite show and you're all staring at me. I was so scared. I remember I was on my knees singing to you. I'll be all crying and at the end of it they asked me to kiss your hand and I was so nervous that actually if you go back and watch the episode you'll see I didn't actually kiss your hand. I missed your hand and kissed my thumb which I get made fun of for a lot. There's also a part in that scene, and this made the final cut, where we did that scene about 20 times, because I remember them saying this is the first time Jim and Pam have actually gotten to a fight on camera.
你们全都是我最喜欢的演员。这是我最喜欢的节目，而你们所有人都盯着我看。我吓坏了。我记得我跪着对你唱歌。我会一直哭泣，最后他们让我吻你的手，我当时太紧张了，实际上如果你回去看那一集，你会发现我并没有真的吻你的手。我亲空了，亲到了自己的大拇指，我为此被嘲笑了好多次。那个场景里还有一个部分，并且最终进入了正片，我们拍那个场景大概拍了20遍，因为我记得他们说这是吉姆和帕姆第一次在镜头前真正吵架。
So it was like a big deal, and the writers were extremely particular about how the fight should sound. So they ended up like rewriting it on the spot several different times. We did several different versions, which meant I had to keep singing that song, which wasn't great for my voice, and probably became progressively worse and worse as we went. But for the very last take, I remember we had done it so many times and I was just like, you know what, screw it. And I was singing to you and you were arguing with Jim while I was singing. So I took my finger, my index finger, and put it towards your mouth to shush you.
所以这算是一件大事，编剧对这场架听起来应该是什么样极其挑剔。所以他们最后在现场即兴重写了好几次。我们拍了好几个不同的版本，这意味着我不得不一直唱那首歌，这对我的嗓子可不太好，随着拍摄的进行，可能也变得越来越糟。但对于最后一条，我记得我们已经拍了无数次，我当时就想：你知道吗，去他的吧。我正对着你唱歌，而你在我唱歌时和吉姆争吵。所以我伸出手指，食指，指着你的嘴唇让你嘘声。
And you broke, you laughed, but it was so funny. We were all laughing. I'll never forget that moment. It was the best of my life. And you said that was so brilliant. And luckily it made the cut you see in the video, me raising my finger to shush you. But yeah, that was so fun and that's something I'll never forget.
然后你破功了，你笑了，但真的太搞笑了。我们都在笑。我永远不会忘记那一刻。那是我生命中最棒的时刻。你说那太绝了。幸运的是，这进入了最终剪辑，你会在视频里看到我抬起手指让你嘘声。但是，是的，真的太有趣了，这是我永远不会忘记的事情。
So lady, I remember when he did that. I remember when he put his finger up to my face to shush me. I can't believe we had enough footage to keep it in the episode because I felt like I immediately broke because I thought that was so funny. But the whole thing was like, he was so earnestly, sweetly singing. It's right. Right. My face.
所以，女士，我还记得他那样做的时候。我还记得他把手指举到我脸上让我嘘声的时候。我真不敢相信我们有足够素材把它留在正片里，因为我觉得我立刻就破功了，因为我觉得太好笑了。但整件事就是，他那么真诚、那么甜美地唱歌。太对了。对。我的脸。
Yeah. It was hard to keep a straight face the whole time. You know, after we filmed this conference room scene, Nick shared that he had a very interesting encounter with Rainn Wilson. Yeah. He sent in an audio clip about it. I want you to hear it because, um, Rainn was not the Cremudge and we know him to be. He was the other audio clip about it. I want you to hear it because Rain was not the Kramudjan we know him to be he was the other part of rain He was and he changed Nick's life. He did. Here's the clip
是的。全程保持严肃太难了。你知道的，在我们拍完这个会议室场景后，尼克分享说他跟雷恩·威尔逊（Rainn Wilson）有过一次非常有趣的相遇。是的。他发来了一段关于这的音频剪辑。我想让你们听听，因为，呃，雷恩并不是我们所熟知的那个脾气暴躁的人。他是音频里的另一部分。我想让你们听听，因为雷恩并不是我们熟知的那个怪脾气，他是雷恩的另一面。他确实是，而且他改变了尼克的人生。他真的改变了。音频在这
Another moment. I'll never forget and actually had a huge impact on my life and my life trajectory Was after the conference room scene or during the conference room scene in between takes, Rainn Wilson was sitting right next to where me and my acapella group were standing and he started conversation and he said, hey, so are you guys actors? And we were like, no, we're from University of Virginia, we're just here to play the acapella group,
另一个瞬间。我永远不会忘记，实际上对我的生活和人生轨迹产生了巨大影响，是在会议室场景之后，或者在会议室场景拍摄间隙，雷恩·威尔逊就坐在我和我的阿卡贝拉团队站立的地方旁边，他挑起话头说：“嘿，所以你们是演员吗？”我们说：“不，我们来自弗吉尼亚大学，我们只是来演阿卡贝拉团体的，
we're acapella group singers. And he pointed to me and he said you should be an actor you should you should consider doing this and This was after I had to scene with a few lines and and sang and I was like so starstrucked and taken aback by that but it really meant a lot to me and Truly is one of the reasons I decided to move out to Los Angeles after I graduated and to pursue this career. So thank you to Rainn Wilson for saying that to me and for giving me a vote of confidence.
我们是阿卡贝拉歌手。”他指着我说道：“你应该去当演员，你应该，你应该考虑做这个。”这发生在我拍了一场有几句台词并唱了歌的戏之后，我当时真的惊为天人、受宠若惊，但这对我意义重大，也确实是我决定在毕业后搬到洛杉矶追求这份事业的原因之一。所以非常感谢雷恩·威尔逊对我说的那番话，以及给我的信心投票。
And you've really had a big impact on my life and I hope that I get to meet him again one day so I can thank him in person because it really meant a lot to me. So there you go, Nick had his Molly Shannon moment with Rain. Oh yes, this is your Molly Shannon moment where she told you to stick with it. Yes, I met her right when I first got to LA. And so Nick took Rain's advice.
你真的对我的生活产生了重大影响，我希望有一天我能再次见到他，这样我就可以当面向他道谢，因为这真的对我意义重大。所以你看，尼克也有了属于他自己的雷恩版“莫莉·香农”时刻。哦对，这就是你的莫莉·香农时刻，当时她叫你坚持下去。是的，我刚到洛杉矶时就遇到了她。所以尼克听取了雷恩的建议。
He moved to LA, he's been in a bunch of commercials, he's been on Blackish and 911 and he is currently in the Sunday company at Groundlings. He's also teamed up with Halstead again and Claire again on different projects. He's now a working actor. This is so crazy. Yeah. All from this like random email that he got one day. He was in college. You know, Nixon and one last clip for us, you guys. And it's about, well, it's about things you learn on set. And one of the guys in the acapella group learned that, well, he didn't understand how the toilet worked in the trailer that they were using. And I think for anyone coming to LA wants to be an actor, this is an important lesson to learn.
他搬去了洛杉矶，演过一堆广告，参演过《喜新不厌旧》（Black-ish）和《911》（9-1-1），目前是喜剧剧团“The Groundlings”周日剧团的成员。他还和霍尔斯特德以及克莱尔在不同的项目中再次合作。他现在是一名职业演员。这太疯狂了。是的。这一切都源于他某天收到的一封随机电子邮件。他当时还在上大学。你知道的，尼克斯还有最后一段音频留给我们，伙计们。关于，嗯，关于你在片场学到的东西。阿卡贝拉团队里的一个人了解到，嗯，他搞不懂他们使用的房车里的厕所是怎么工作的。我想对于任何去洛杉矶想成为演员的人来说，这是必须学懂的一课。
Let's hear it. Okay, so this story is one that you would probably never share, but I have to tell you because it's just too outrageous to not. When we were there, there were eight of us, and so we all got trailers on set and we shared them with each other, at least little honey wagons. There were two per each trailer. The trailers are small. They have a little couch and a little closet to put your costumes in and a tiny little
我们来听听看。好吧，这个故事你可能永远不会分享，但我必须告诉你，因为它实在太离谱了，不吐不快。当时我们在那里，我们有八个人，所以我们在片场都有房车，我们互相共用，至少是小保姆车（honey wagon）。每辆房车有两个。房车很小。里面有一个小沙发和一个用来挂戏服的小壁橱，还有一个极小的
bathroom. I remember I shared my trailer with one of my fellow acapella group members whose name I will not mention for reasons that will soon become obvious. I remember he was in the trailer. I was going to go get fitted. When my fitting was done, I came back to walk up the stairs to our trailer. And as I did, he burst through the door,
卫生间。我记得我和我的一位阿卡贝拉团队成员共用一辆房车，为了不久后就会显而易见的原因，我就不透露他的名字了。我记得他在房车里。我要去试装。等我试装完回来，走台阶上我们的房车。正当我这么做时，他突然冲出房门，
carrying a giant wad of paper towels and kind of like rushing down the stairs past me. And I was like, okay, that's strange. And he went and threw him in a trash can. I was like, okay, cool. That was a lot of paper threw him in a trash can. I was like, okay, cool. That was a lot of paper towels. I get back in the trailer, I'm sitting there, he comes in, and I'm like, oh, it smells off in here.
手里抓着一大团纸巾，像冲刺一样从我身边的台阶上跑下去。我当时想：好吧，这挺奇怪的。他走过去把纸扔进了垃圾桶。我当时想：好吧，酷。扔了那么多纸……扔进垃圾桶了，我当时想：好吧，酷。那是好多纸巾。我回到房车里坐下，他走进来，然后我说：哦，这里面味道有点不对劲。
Did you like pass gas or use the bathroom? And he was like, no, no, no, no. And I was like, dude, are you sure? It smells like somebody went to the bathroom and took a poop. And I was like, are you sure? He's like, okay, yes, I did. I used, went to the bathroom and took a poop. And I was like, are you sure? He's like, okay, yes, I did. I used, went to the bathroom in the toilet
你是不是放屁了还是上厕所了？他说：没有没有没有没有。我说：老兄，你确定吗？闻起来就像有人上厕所拉了屎。然后我说：你确定吗？他说：好吧，是的，我确实拉了。我用了，去厕所拉了屎。然后我说：你确定吗？他说：好吧，是的，我确实拉了。我用了，在马桶上上厕所
and it doesn't work, it doesn't flush. So I had to take all the paper towels and pick it up and throw it out in the trash. And I was like, oh my God, are you kidding me? It turned out the toilet was one of the ones that had a foot pedal. There's a pedal underneath the toilet that you push down with your foot and it flushes. And he didn't know that and couldn't find that.
结果没用，冲不了水。所以我只好用纸巾把那些东西捡起来，扔进垃圾桶里。当时我想，天哪，你开什么玩笑？原来那个马桶是带脚踏的。马桶下方有个踏板，你用脚往下踩就能冲水。他不知道这一点，也找不到那个踏板。
He just thought it was a broken toilet. So he panicked, wrapped his hands in paper towels and picked up his own mess, ran it through the door and threw it away in a trash can. I was mortified to hear this. I have never heard of more unhinged behavior. I was like, dude, it's just a foot pedal. You have ruined Dunder Mifflin. This is so, yeah, to anybody who emptied the trash over there, I apologize on his behalf. Yeah, I know that's disgusting, but I mean, it's just so outrageous. You can't make that stuff up.
他以为马桶坏了。于是他慌了，用纸巾包着手，捡起自己的排泄物，开门跑出去，扔进了一个垃圾桶里。听到这事我惊呆了。我从未听说过如此精神错乱的行为。当时我就想，老兄，那只是个脚踏板。你把邓德米弗林毁了。所以，是的，对于任何清理过那边垃圾的人，我替他向你们道歉。是的，我知道这很恶心，但我的意思是，这也太离谱了。这种事你编都编不出来。
I had to share it. Sorry. Here's my question after hearing that story. What is that guy's nickname now? Oh, my gosh. What is his nickname? Shers full. I don't know. I do have to say this is something that I struggled with the first time I was in a trailer. It took me a very long time to figure out how to flush the toilet.
我不得不分享一下。抱听完这个故事，我有问题了。那家伙现在外号叫什么？哦，天哪。他的外号是什么？粪桶满满。我不知道。我必须承认，我第一次进房车时，这也是我纠结的事情。我花了很长时间才弄清楚怎么冲马桶。
Yes. I should maybe put this in my book. Next book. Yeah, my acting advice book. Sometimes toilets have a foot pedal. Look for the foot. Don't panic. Don't panic.
是的。我或许该把它写进我的书里。下一本书。对，我的表演建议书。有时候马桶是有脚踏板的。找找那个脚。别慌。别慌。
Because you're already a little panicked just because you're there. Yes. And I, you know, you should know how to flush your toilet. Well, Nick, thank you so much for sharing all of your stories with us. Guys, you can follow Nick over on Instagram at ncafaro.nysusguy. Thank you so much. Yes, Nick. Those were so fun.
因为你本来就有点慌，只因为你在那里。是的，而且，你知道的，你应该知道怎么冲马桶。尼克，非常感谢你跟我们分享你所有的故事。各位，你们可以在Instagram上关注尼克，账号是ncafaro.nysusguy。非常感谢。是的，尼克。太有趣了。
Well, there's a time cut now in the conference room. It's a little bit now in the conference room. It's a little bit later. The acapella group is still singing. They're singing the song Car Wash. Clark is really into it. The senator nods to Oscar. Looks like they're going to maybe go find a place to meet up.
会议室现在有一处时间剪辑。现在会议室里过了一会儿。无伴奏合唱团还在唱。他们在唱《洗车歌》。克拉克非常投入。参议员向奥斯卡点了点头。看起来他们可能要去某个地方碰头了。
Now the acapella guys are going to say, we've got a special treat for you. They start singing Andy's signature song, Faith. He pops up, he's shaking his tush, but guess who appears on the television behind them? Broccoli Rob. And he's singing it too. Yeah. And Andy's like, what the hell? And they're like, well, this is Broccoli Rob's signature
现在无伴奏合唱团的人要说，我们有个特别的惊喜给你们。他们开始唱安迪的标志性歌曲《信仰》。他蹦了起来，扭着屁股，但猜猜谁出现在他们身后的电视上？西兰花罗布。他也唱着这首歌。对。安迪一脸“搞什么鬼”，他们则说，嗯，这是西兰花罗布的标志性
song. We thought you wanted to hear it. This is too much for Andy. First of all, broccoli Rob took boner champ from him and now his signature song? Mm-hmm. We got a fan question from Sophie H. in England who said, please tell us how much you had to pay for all of the songs.
歌曲。我们以为你想听。这对安迪来说太过分了。首先，西兰花罗布抢了他的“处男冠军”，现在连他的标志性歌曲也抢了？嗯哼。我们收到了来自英国的索菲·H的粉丝提问，她说，请告诉我们，所有这些歌曲你们付了多少版权费。
Sophie, Steve Burgess said, our music people did a lot of negotiating for these songs. I bet. Faith was the most expensive. We paid $30,000 for faith. All of the other songs were negotiated for 20,000 and Car Wash was free. Oh.
索菲，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，我们的音乐团队为这些歌曲进行了大量的谈判。我敢说。《信仰》是最贵的。我们为《信仰》付了3万美元。所有其他歌曲的版权都谈判到了2万美元，而《洗车歌》是免费的。哦。
You know, Claire said that when she was prepping this episode, the most difficult part was prepping all these songs. Like you said, Angela, they did a ton of rehearsal, but she said in particular, anytime people were singing and there was dialogue, it was really tricky because they had to be able to get all of it. And it gets really hard to cut. To edit around that.
你知道，克莱尔说，当她筹备这一集时，最困难的部分就是筹备所有这些歌曲。正如你们所说，安吉拉，他们排练了无数次，但她说特别是每当有人唱歌又有台词时，这真的很棘手，因为他们必须把所有这些都拍下来。而且周围的剪辑变得非常困难。围绕这一点进行剪辑。
Yeah, Jim and I weren't always fighting or saying our lines at the exact same time as other takes. It's hard to do. So she said as a director, that was probably the most challenging part about shooting this episode. Well, we got a fan question from Ceciaze in London, Ontario, Canada. Ceciaze says, when here comes trouble, starts singing faith and broccoli Rob comes in singing, he doesn't stop
对，我和吉姆并不总是像其他镜头那样，在完全相同的时间打架或说台词。这很难做到。所以她说，作为导演，这可能是拍摄这一集最具挑战性的部分。嗯，我们收到了来自加拿大安大略省伦敦市塞西亚斯的粉丝提问。塞西亚斯说，当“麻烦驾到”开始唱《信仰》，西兰花罗布进来合唱时，他没有停下
singing, even when Andy stops the group. It made it seem like it was a recording of Broccoli Rob, but in the next scene, Andy is having a whole conversation with him like it's a video chat. I see the camera, but I'm wondering if there was a missing scene that explained this transition. Well, there was some missing dialogue that would have explained it.
唱歌，甚至在安迪叫停组合时也没有停。这让人觉得这是西兰花罗布的录音，但在下一个镜头中，安迪却像视频聊天一样跟他进行了整段对话。我看到了摄像机，但我想知道是不是漏掉了一个解释这种过渡的场景。嗯，确实有一些本可以解释这一点的缺失台词。
Per the script, Rob finally stopped singing, and then he says, oh, I had the audio off on my end, fellas, but it felt like I hit that one out of the park. Right. Yes. But great catch, Sessia. Well, like you said, Andy is going to confront Broccoli Rob now. Yeah. And what is up with Broccoli Rob's apartment?
根据剧本，罗布终于停止唱歌，然后他说，哦，我这边把音频关了，伙计们，但我觉得我刚才那一首唱得太棒了。对的。是的，不过捕捉得真棒，塞西亚。嗯，正如你所说，安迪现在要去质问西兰花罗布了。对。西兰花罗布的公寓是怎么回事？
I mean, he says he still lives close to campus. Does he live in a dorm room? I'm very confused. What has happened to Broccoli Rob? Oh, you know what? I bet he's like the RA. Maybe. I don't know.
我的意思是，他说他仍然住在离校园很近的地方。他住在宿舍里吗？我很糊涂。西兰花罗布到底怎么了？哦，你知道吗？我敢说他就像是住宿舍监。也许吧。我不知道。
It was like he just, he looks like he's living in a frat house or something maybe. He has just like a leather couch. It's not filled out in any way. It looks like a lamp is sitting on the floor. It's very, very college looking is what I'll say. Their fight escalates to this crazy challenge where they're going to have a sing off for the rights
感觉就像他，他看起来像是住在兄弟会宿舍或类似的地方。他只有一个皮质沙发。里面什么也没有塞满，看起来就像一盏台词放在地板上。我要说的是，这看起来非常非常像大学宿舍。他们的争吵升级为一场疯狂的挑战，他们将进行一场歌唱比赛，争夺歌曲
to the song, faith. And Erin has had enough. She just unplugged the TV because the guys are just yelling at each other. Andy and Erin then have a big talk in the conference room, and Erin is losing respect for Andy in all of this. She's like, this is kind of ridiculous, right? Well, yeah, she had a talking head earlier where she's like, you know, when you're with
《信仰》的版权。艾琳受够了。她直接拔掉了电视插头，因为这群人在互相大喊大叫。安迪和艾琳随后在会议室里进行了长谈，艾琳对安迪的好感在这过程中一点点消磨殆尽。她觉得，这有点荒谬，对吧？好吧，是的，她之前有一个“单人访谈”，里面说，你知道，当你和
someone, you just have to put up with the stuff that makes you lose respect for them. That's love. Yeah. Andy is now going to suggest that maybe, you know, just maybe if he were closer to Cornell sharing his stories, he'd be the one, all the guys remember. You know what? Oh my God, maybe they should move there.
某人在一起时，你只能忍受那些让你对他们失去尊敬的事情。这就是爱。是的。安迪现在要暗示，也许，你知道，只要他离康奈尔大学更近一点，分享他的故事，他就会成为所有人记住的那个人。你知道吗？哦，天哪，也许他们应该搬到那里去。
And Aaron's like, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. But then he has another idea. I know what if I made a big donation from the Bernard Family Foundation? To the acapella group. Yes. Yeah, that's it. Then he would get the respect he deserves.
然后艾琳说，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇。但接着他有了另一个主意。我知道，如果我以伯纳德家族基金会的名义进行一大笔捐款呢？捐给无伴奏合唱团。是的。对，就是这样。这样他就能获得他应得的尊重。
Because, and I quote, if I'm not boner champ, I don't know who I am. Yeah. Now at Front Reception, a group has gathered. They're eating some candy. They're chatting about the concert. Kevin really liked it. Angela said, you know what?
因为，引述他的话，“如果我不是‘处男冠军’，我都不知道我是谁了。”是的。现在在前台接待处，聚集了一群人。他们正在吃一些糖果。他们在聊音乐会的事。凯文真的很喜欢。安吉拉说，你知道吗？
They lost me when they sang Monster Mash. It just glorifies the occult. And Jim's like, hey, you know what? Angela relax, it's Halloween, it's a Halloween song. They have to sing it, they have to. And Pam is like, oh, they have to? They have to, Jim? Oh, he should have never said have to.
当他们唱《怪物狂欢》时，他们让我粉转黑了。这简直是在美化异教崇拜。吉姆就说，嘿，你知道吗？安吉拉放轻松点，这是万圣节，这是一首万圣节歌曲。他们必须唱，他们必须唱。帕姆就说，哦，他们必须唱？他们必须唱，吉姆？哦，他真不该说“必须”这两个字。
That was it. That's right. What would happen if they didn't sing it, Jim? Would someone go to jail? Would they be shot? I'm generally interested in knowing your definition of have to is basically what she's saying. One of the funniest things during the scene to me is Brian is Kevin, his performance. He looks at you. He's trying to sort out Pam's rationale in this argument, and then he looks at Jim and he's just going, huh? I'll have you know that as producer,
就是这样。没错。吉姆，如果他们不唱会发生什么？有人会坐牢吗？会被枪毙吗？我其实挺想知道你对“必须”的定义是什么，她基本上就是这么说的。在这场戏中，对我和最有趣的事情之一就是布莱恩饰演的凯文，他的表现。他看着你。他试图理清帕姆在这个争论中的逻辑，然后他看着吉姆，嘴里说着，哈？我要让你们知道，作为制片人，
I would get scripts very early. And when I read this Monster Mash scene, I was unsure about it. I turned in my notes and I said, I really felt like Jim and Pam should have like a spy shot real fight about this. I didn't think it should be played comedically. Right.
我很早就拿到了剧本。当我读到这个《怪物狂欢》的场景时，我对此很不确定。我交上了我的意见，我说，我真的觉得吉姆和帕姆应该就此展开一场像偷拍视角的真正争吵。我不认为应该以喜剧的方式来演绎。对。
This was my note. I'm gonna say I stand corrected. I really like this scene. I love how it came out. But I had sent back in my notes a whole pitch for what I thought the dialogue should have been between Jim and Pam. In terms of this argument,
这就是我的意见。我要说我收回前言。我真的很喜欢这个场景。我喜欢它的呈现方式。但我之前交回的意见里有一整套关于我认为吉姆和帕姆之间应该有什么样台词的构想。就这场争论而言，
I clearly was writing for a drama, but here's how I thought it should have played out. I wanted them to find us in the middle of a fight in a spy shot, and here's how it would have gone. Jim would say, you have to let me make judgment calls. This is a new business. You weren't in the room. I really felt like in order to be taken seriously,
我显然是在为一部正剧撰写台词，但这是我当时认为它应该呈现的方式。我希望他们通过偷拍视角发现在争吵正酣的我们，而过程会是这样的。吉姆会说，你得让我做决定。这是一项新业务。你当时不在房间里。我真的觉得要想被重视，
I had to invest. You can't micromanage this, Pam. And then Pam would have said, I'm not telling you what office to get or what clients to take, but I must get a say in what happens with our money. If it's about our family, I have a say. And Jim said,
我必须投资。你不能事事干预，帕姆。然后帕姆会说，我没有告诉你要找哪个办公室或接纳哪个客户，但对于我们钱的去向，我必须有发言权。如果是关于我们家庭的事，我有发言权。然后吉姆说，
Exactly, and you agreed we could invest. And Pam would have said, That's when I thought we had to invest. And Jim said, You're acting like I'm doing this for something other than our family. That's the whole point. And Pam would have said, Really? Because part of me feels like you're just doing this for something other than our family. That's the whole point. And Pam would have said, really? Because part of me feels like you're just doing it for you.
没错，你也同意我们可以投资。帕姆会说，那是我以为我们不得不投资的时候。吉姆说，你表现得好像我做这一切是为了我们家庭之外的事情。这才是重点。帕姆会说，真的吗？因为我总觉得你做这一切只是为了你自己。
Well, that's a real fight. I know. That's like taken out of almost every marriage fight out there, versions of that. And I put in parentheses in my notes, maybe that last part is too far and better saved for later in the season. But I still want it to happen.
好吧，这真是一场争吵。我知道。这几乎取材于现实生活中的每一次婚姻争吵，都有类似的版本。我在意见里用括号写着，也许最后一部分有点过火了，留到本季晚些时候再用会更好。但我还是希望它发生。
But you know, what I was going for was I wanted to get into the nitty gritty of this situation. I wanted Jim to stand up for himself a little bit, because in the way that this is happening, I can tell you right now, I could never be married to Jim. The hemming in the hawing, the wishy-washy, and then the big swings into impulsive behavior, this would drive me absolutely nuts. Like, I couldn't handle it. And so I think that, you know, I wanted to handle it how Jenna would handle it. Right, not how Pam. Luckily, there was a roomful of writers who made sure that Pam handled it,
但你知道，我的初衷是想深入探讨这种情况的本质。我想让吉姆为自己辩护一点点，因为以这种方式发生的事情，我现在就可以告诉你，我绝对不可能嫁给吉姆。那些犹豫不决、含糊其辞，然后又突然做出冲动行为的大反转，这绝对会把我逼疯的。比如，我根本承受不了。所以我想，你知道的，我想按照珍娜会处理的方式来处理。对，而不是帕姆会处理的方式。幸运的是，有一屋子的编剧确保了帕姆是以
how Pam would handle it. Well, Claire shared with us that this scene leads to one of her favorite Kevin Talking heads. It's also one of my favorites. Also one of my favorites. And I thought we should hear it. It turns out Pam really really really hates Monster Mash. I mean like never bring
帕姆会处理的方式来处理的。嗯，克莱尔跟我们分享说，这一幕造就了她最喜欢的凯文单人访谈之一。这也是我的最爱之一。也是我的最爱之一。我觉得我们应该听听看。原来帕姆真的非常非常讨厌《怪物狂欢》。我的意思是，绝不要在她面前提起
that song up in front of her. Even though Jim was making great points like in favor of the song, Pam was like no hate it stupid. You know, this is the moment where a lot of people turn on Pam too because they think she's being irrationally angry at Jim because he did something that she agreed to. But you're missing, when we originally wrote this episode, he did do something without asking her, which was investing more than they agreed on. Yeah. When he didn't have to at all. when he didn't have to at all. When he didn't have to at all.
那首歌。尽管吉姆提出了很多支持这首歌的绝佳观点，但帕姆的态度是，不，讨厌，真愚蠢。你知道，这也是许多人对帕姆粉转黑的时刻，因为他们觉得她对吉姆表现出无理取闹的愤怒，因为吉姆做了一件她同意过的事。但你们忽略了，当我们最初写这一集时，他确实在没有征求她意见的情况下做了一件事，那就是投资超过了他们商定的金额。对。明明他根本没必要这么做。明明他根本没必要这么做。明明他根本没必要这么做。
I want you to know in the original script, there was a beat that I did successfully argue should be cut and I stand by it. When Jim and Pam are leaving for the day and they get in their car, Jim turns on Monster Mash and looks at Pam as a way of trying to smooth things over. My gosh. And I was like, that's kind of a dick move.
我想让你们知道，在最初的剧本中，有一个节拍我成功地力争将其删掉了，我坚持我的看法。当吉姆和帕姆一天工作结束准备离开、坐进车里时，吉姆打开了《怪物狂欢》，看着帕姆，试图以此来缓和气氛。天哪。当时我觉得这真是个混蛋行为。
I was like, I don't think Pam's gonna have a real sense of humor for that. Yeah. You know what, Kevin could tell you not to do that. It was pitched maybe it would make Pam laugh and I said, I think we need to leave the tension. Yeah, no, she wouldn't move on that quickly. I didn't think so. Well, back to this Dwight Nellie,
当时我想，我觉得帕姆不会觉得这有什么幽默感的。是的。你知道吗，凯文可以告诉你别这么做。当时有人提议说这也许会逗笑帕姆，而我说，我觉得我们需要保留这种紧张感。是的，不，她不会那么快翻篇的。我可不这么认为。好了，回到德怀特和内莉这个
mom detective moment, Nellie eventually says, Dwight, look, it's my pill. All right, I deal with some anxiety. It's not a big deal. And I think this kind of puts life and perspective for Dwight. He says, you know what? I might want some of those pills for my cousin because he's had a tough time being wifeless
妈咪侦探的时刻，内莉最后说，德怀特，听着，那是我的药丸。好吧，我有点焦虑。这没什么大不了的。我想这让德怀特对生活有了不同的认识。他说，你知道吗？我可能想给我表哥弄点那种药，因为他在没有妻子的
with a high pressure job. And also he has a crazy cousin named Moe's. And Nelly says, you know what? He's a good man and she hopes he feels better. Yes, he's clearly talking about himself. And we got a fan question from Jade O. in Los Angeles who said, Dwight talks to Nelly about getting a prescription for anxiety medicine.
情况下还要应付高压工作，日子过得很艰难。而且他还有一个叫莫斯的疯表哥。内莉说，你知道吗？他是个好人，她希望他能感觉好点。是的，他显然是在说他自己。我们收到了来自洛杉矶的杰德·O的粉丝提问，她说，德怀特跟内莉谈到开抗焦虑药物处方的事。
And then later, he reveals in the Christmas episode that he has been taking them. Is this the reason why he seems so much calmer in the rest of the series? It felt like there was a shift in his personality, and he went through a lot of character growth. He seemed much happier and friendlier to everyone for the rest of the series after this episode. Jade, I'm gonna track that now. Yeah. I'm gonna pay attention. This is a great observation. I mean, I know they were setting up Dwight for a possible spin-off in the farm, and they needed him to be able to leave Dunder Mifflin. So they were setting up Dwight to sort of have some big
然后后来，他在圣诞节那一集里透露他一直在服用这些药。这就是为什么他在剧集剩下的部分看起来平静了那么多的原因吗？感觉他的性格发生了转变，他经历了很多角色成长。自这一集之后，在剧集剩下的时间里，他看起来快乐多了，对每个人也更友好了。杰德，我接下来要留意一下。是的。我要多加注意。这是一个很棒的观察。我是说，我知道他们在为德怀特在《农场》中可能的衍生剧做铺垫，他们需要他能够离开邓德米弗林。所以他们是在为德怀特做铺垫，让他有一些重大的
life realization moments. His job there is stressful. He is wifeless. Like these things that might make him move on to another place. This episode wraps up with a bit of a montage during which several things happen. We find out that Andy's parents are broke. Yeah. Toby tries to bring some flowers to Nelly, but when she takes her Toby wig off, he's no longer interested. I looked what it said in the shooting draft for that. What did it say?
人生顿悟时刻。他在那里工作压力很大。他没有妻子。这些事情可能会促使他搬去另一个地方。这一集在一段蒙太奇中落下帷幕，其间发生了一些事情。我们发现安迪的父母破产了。是的。托比试图给内莉送一些花，但当内莉摘下她的托比假发时，他对她不再感兴趣了。我查了拍摄初稿里是怎么写的。上面写了什么？
It says Nelly is packing up to leave for the day. Toby appears from the annex, approaches her holding some flowers. He looks nervous. Nelly, not noticing him, pulls off her Toby wig, releasing her normal hair. Something in Toby dies. Nelly notices him, hi Toby, who are the flowers for? Toby, nobody. He throws the flowers in a trash can and crosses off. It's over for him.
上面写着内莉正在收拾东西准备下班回家。托比从附楼出现，拿着一些花向她走去。他看起来很紧张。内莉没有注意到他，扯掉了她的托比假发，露出了她原本的头发。托比内心有什么东西死掉了。内莉注意到他，嗨，托比，花是送给谁的？托比：没谁。他把花扔进垃圾桶，然后走开。对他来说，一切都结束了。
Toby just wanted Toby. And finally, we have a spy shot of the senator and Oscar outside and they are making out. They are making out and then as they part ways, Oscar sees the camera busted. Well, everyone, that was Here Comes Treble. A big thank you to Halstead Sullivan, Claire Scanlon, Nick Caferro, Steve Burgess. What an episode!
托比只想要托比。最后，我们看到了参议员和奥斯卡在外面的偷拍画面，他们在热吻。他们在热吻，然后当他们分道扬镳时，奥斯卡看到摄像头暴露了。好了，各位，这就是《麻烦驾到》。非常感谢霍尔斯特德·沙利文、克莱尔·斯坎伦、尼克·卡费罗、史蒂夫·伯吉斯。多么棒的一集啊！
And thanks you guys for sending in your questions and comments. We love hearing from you. See you next week! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy.
谢谢你们发来问题和评论。我们很喜欢听取你们的意见。下周见！感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲。
And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的助理制作人是艾因斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。